And I'm really convinced that by the
grace of Allah, you will take the
shahada one day. I definitely believe
the Bible's corrupted. There's no doubt
in my mind about that. Joseph Smith,
like what on what basis did he add these
verses to to Genesis?
>> You know what his basis was? He got a
revelation from an angel and told him
he's a prophet and that he's prophesied
in the previous scriptures. Does that
sound familiar, Sully?
>> Yeah. He's given me uh a lot to to think
about.
>> Yeah, man. Uh yeah, Logic, it's been
it's been a turbulent week for me as you
know, but you know, I feel I feel as if
you know, I've left Islam. I was almost
in tears, man. Cuz yeah,
>> my granddad who I loved two years ago,
he died as a Muslim. And uh if
Christianity is true, then I'll never
get to see him again.
>> My girlfriend, she's a Muslim. I wanted
to marry her. M
>> like it's really affected so many
things.
>> Yeah.
>> But at the end of at the end of the day
when when you see it, you can't unsee
it.
>> S what's up?
>> Hey man. Uh I'm full Muslim. Just
warning you. I'm I'm full Muslim. But
like not not in a bad way.
>> There's that only means a bad way.
There's no good way to be
>> I'm a good I'm a good full Muslim.
Impossible. That's impossible.
>> No, man. No, man. I like you, man. You
You don't You don't eat the Quran and
and stuff like that. But yeah, for the
question, uh, did Jesus teach
Christianity or Islam? You know, I think
it's pretty clear that he was a Muslim.
You know, he was a Muslim. Your
scripture says he wasn't a Muslim. Not a
Muslim in the sense that we have today,
but a Muslim in the sense of his message
of submitting to Allah. And you know,
Muslim Yeah. Yeah. I'm going to point
you to uh two scriptures. Uh Mark 10:18.
>> Yeah. Mark 10:18
where Jesus says that why do you call me
good? Only the father is good. That
>> he doesn't say the father is good. He
says there's none. He doesn't say only
the father is good. He says there's none
good but God alone.
>> Yeah, maybe maybe I'm paraphrasing. But
>> no, you didn't paraphrase.
>> You get what I'm saying?
>> So is Jesus good?
>> Isa Isaam is good. Of course,
>> he's God then, right?
>> According to your scripture, he's good
in a prophet sense. He is good in a
prophet sense. But according to your
scripture,
>> see, yeah, according to my scripture, is
Jesus good? According to that verse,
according to those verses, he is good,
but he's not good in a in a in a in a
God sense.
>> In what way, in what way is God good
that Jesus isn't?
>> In what way is God good that Jesus
isn't? Uh, well, God is the creator of
everything. You know, he's
>> so So is Jesus. John chapter 1:es 1-3.
Colossians chapter 1 15 to 18.
>> Yeah. But none
>> in my in my opinion my opinion John I
mean it's not even my opinion uh John is
not part of the synoptic gospels
>> it comes later
>> it comes later that it's it's the it's
the gospel where it really introduces
the idea of Jesus being God. The other
three gospels do this
>> Mark Mark literally starts off teaching
that Jesus is God.
>> Where what verse in verse in verse one
to three. Okay. The beginning of the
good news about Jesus the Messiah, the
son of God. As it is written in Isaiah
the prophet, I will send my messenger
ahead of you who will prepare your way.
A voice of one calling in the
wilderness. Prepare the way for the
Lord. Make straight paths for him.
>> So, who's the voice in the wilderness
that's coming before the Lord comes.
>> Who is the voice in the wilderness? I
think that's I'm I'm not sure. I'm not
really sure about
>> the book of Isaiah. It may be uh
>> the people the body of Israel.
>> Mark Mark tells you. Go ahead and keep
reading. Keep reading. Right after it
says this, who does it mention?
>> And so John the Baptist appeared in the
wilderness preaching a baptism of
repentance for the forgiveness of sins.
>> So
who's the voice in the wilderness that's
comes before the Lord comes? Uh John the
Baptist.
>> That's right. And all right. So now keep
reading. And John the Baptist goes on to
tell you who he's preparing the way for.
Who's the Lord that he's preparing the
way for? Keep reading.
>> All right. Uh the whole Judean
countryside and all the people of
Jerusalem went out to him confessing
their sins. They were baptized by him in
the Jordan River. John wore clothing
made of camel<unk>s hair with a leather
belt around his waist. And he ate
locusts and wild honey. And this was his
message. After me comes the one more
powerful than I. The straps of whose
sandals I am not worthy to stoop down
and untie. I baptize you with water, but
he will baptize you with the Holy
Spirit.
>> Very good. So the one that John is
preparing the way for is much more
powerful than him. He's not even worthy
to stoop down and untie his sandals. And
how John baptizes with water, the one
who's coming after him, who's who he's
preparing the way for, the Lord, he's
preparing the way for is going to
baptize with the Holy Spirit. Who is
this? Keep reading. It tells you who the
who that one is.
>> I don't need to keep reading. That's
Jesus.
>> Exactly. So the Lord who is coming that
Isaiah that Isaiah the prophet is
talking about Isaiah is is saying that
the voice in the wilderness who's John
the Baptist prepares the way for the
Lord and the Lord that he that that he's
talking about is Jesus. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Now this means that right in the
beginning of Mark's gospel he's
identifying Jesus as God. Right.
>> No I he's not no wait hold on. He's not
identifying him as God. Like nothing in
this passage is Islam whatsoever.
>> You ready? Watch this. He said prophet
He said the prophet Isaiah, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Go to go to Isaiah chapter 40. So who
who does Isaiah say it is? Let's go.
>> Okay. Isaiah 40. Comfort comfort my
people, says your God.
>> Verse three and five. Verse verses 3 to
five.
>> Verse three to five. A voice of one
calling in the wilderness. Prepare the
way for the Lord. Make straight in the
desert a highway for our God. Every
valley shall be raised up. Every
mountain and hill made low. The rough
ground shall become level and the rugged
places of plain. And the glory of the
Lord shall be will be revealed and all
my people will see it together. For the
mouth of the Lord has spoken.
>> So according to the prophecy, the voice
in the wilderness is preparing the way
for the Lord God. Correct. Yeah. For uh
prepare the way of the Lord, make
straight in the desert, a highway for
our God. Um it seems like it's preparing
>> like a symbol, something like a kingdom
or something. It's it's more of like a
pathway.
>> It's a preparing the pathway for God to
come,
>> right?
>> Yeah. I Isaiah is not in the New
Testament.
>> I I agree with you. He's not in the New
Testament. But what he says here is that
he's is that the voice in the wilderness
is preparing the way for God to come.
Correct? God is coming after this voice
in the wilderness. Right.
>> Wait, could I could I continue reading,
>> brother? That's not irrelevant.
I need you to answer this right here.
What we just read.
>> Every valley shall be lifted up.
>> This right here.
>> All right. In the wilderness, prepare a
way. Prepare the way of the Lord. Make
straight in the desert a highway for our
God. Okay.
>> So, who's coming after the voice in the
wilderness?
>> The Lord.
>> The Lord God, right?
>> Appears to be.
>> So, and who does Mark say the one that
Lord God is that Isaiah is talking
about? Who does Mark say this is about?
>> Mark says it's about like it's about
Jesus.
>> Exactly.
>> I I I can grant that, you know. I can
grant that that he says it's about
Jesus. The problem I have is is with the
gospels is what the the gospel writers
say contradicts what Jesus himself says.
>> That wasn't your argument at first. Your
argument at first was is that John is a
later gospel from the synoptics and it's
not until John that we see in the gospel
that Jesus is God or being portrayed as
God. I said no. I said Mark in the Hold
on.
>> I I said Mark in the very beginning of
his gospel establishes that Jesus is
God.
>> So can we agree that Mark establishes
right in the beginning that Jesus is God
who was coming after the voice in the
wilderness John the Baptist? Can we
agree?
>> Yeah. Yeah, we can agree on that. The
the the thing is like before I came on
the show I I read actually the gospels
but I didn't have the context of Isaiah
40. So I can I can agree with you.
>> Awesome. So way but before John gets
written down because I agree with you
John and all the church fathers agree
with you. John wrote his gospel after
the synoptis gospels were written.
You're right about that. However, this
idea that this concept of Jesus being
God is an evolution is false. In the
earliest gospels, even according to
their standard, in the earliest gospel
that we have, Jesus is established as
being God Almighty.
>> Yeah. The the the thing is the like I
said, you guys don't really have taps.
So, a lot of this
>> Yes, we do. We got church fathers, bro.
>> Yeah. But like it's not it's not like
when you read the Bible there's no
there's no taps here to explain okay
Isaiah says this. If I if if I had the
context like it would be different.
>> What do you mean? Mark Mark just said
what Isaiah said. He quoted in it and
and explain.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I get what you're saying.
But like as someone who's not a
Christian, if I read the Bible, there
should be something that that's like,
"Hey, go to Isaiah 40 so you can
understand what Mark's saying." Well,
all you have to do, brother, is when it
says in the w uh as Isaiah the prophet
said, Mark tells you who he's quoting.
He says, "Go in Isaiah the prophet," and
all you got to do is look up a voice
crying in the wilderness, book of
Isaiah, and it pops right up. What are
you talking about?
>> All right. All right. Fine. Like, all
right, Logic. Look, I I I concede on
that, you know, like I didn't notice it
when I read it. You're right on that. My
my thing is that it it doesn't even
really contradict Islam because you know
the ine
like let's look at Jesus's specific
quotes
>> like where like Matthew like what I said
about Matthew Matthew 19:17 like are we
just going to ignore that where he says
that don't call me good only
>> he never says don't call me good he
doesn't say that
>> yeah pardon me wait let look for the
exact verse he says He says,
>> "Why do you call me good? No one is good
but one that is God.
>> But if you want to enter into life, keep
the commandments." How is this different
from Islam?
>> The the thing is that what the the the
the disciples had
>> is different from what Jesus says.
>> Okay, I got you. So I I'm I'm a little
confused again. So we're back here.
>> We already see that Mark and by the way,
just to let you know, Matthew does the
same thing in the beginning of his
gospel. He also quotes, all of them do.
Matthew does it, Luke does it, Mark does
it. They all refer back to Isaiah 40:3
and Malachi 3:1 saying the same thing,
the voice crying in the wilderness, the
messenger preparing the way for God to
come. They all quote that, all of them,
and say that it's about Jesus. So, they
all establish in the beginning of their
gospel, in the beginning of the gospel
of Jesus, that Jesus is God. Now, you
get to to where Jesus is testing the
young ruler and he says, "Why do you
call me good? There's no none good
except God alone. I'll ask you the
question again. Is Jesus good?
>> Jesus is good. Yeah, we we respect him.
He is good. Same way Moses is good.
>> Oh, no.
>> And Muhammad the prophet is good.
>> So So then that means that all the
prophets are good.
>> Since Jesus is good, then he's God then.
Is that right?
>> Well, let me ask you a question. the the
the Quran says that Allah is is the
truth. But if I say God logic is
truthful, does it mean that God logic is
God?
>> No. But what if you say God logic is the
truth? Then are you saying that I'm God?
>> If I say God logic is is the truth?
>> Yeah. If you say that I am al-Hawk, the
truth, are you saying that I'm you're
you're claiming that I'm God, right?
>> Yeah. That's that's sherk. Yeah, that
would be sherk. So there's a difference
between saying that I'm truthful,
meaning I I have the attribute of being
truthful in calling me the truth itself.
That's a title and name for God alone.
Can we agree?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> And so this is interesting because this
is a title that Jesus claims for
himself.
>> Oh no. No.
>> He says, "I am the way. I am alah, the
truth.
and I am the life. That's what Jesus
says. So when Jesus says, "I am the
truth," he's claiming to be God, right?
>> I am the truth. The Oh, uh, let me ask
you this.
>> I am the truth. I am the life. No.
Answer this. When Jesus says, since we
agree, to call someone else the truth
would be sh, right? You'll be claiming
that that person is God. You'll be
associating them with God. So when Jesus
says it, he says, "I am the truth." Can
we be honest and agree that Jesus is
claiming to be God?
>> With the Quranic context, it would
appear to be so. But I'm going to ask
you another question. I'm going to ask
you another question.
>> Wait, wait. We can't let we can't just
slide by that just like
>> No, cuz you can't. No. Come on, man.
Come on. Come on. Perventure.
Perfect.
Be fair. Be fair with me. Like this.
This isn't fair. I I have a question.
>> Wait,
>> another name of
>> you. You know, you know, I'm going to
let you ask it. You I I you man. All
right. All right.
>> I want to I want to make sure that we
that we that we stick this in. So,
you're saying that from the even from
the Quranic standards,
Jesus claiming to be truth is him Jesus
claiming to be the truth is Jesus
claiming to be God. We agree.
Look, do do you have the uh the original
like
>> Come on, man. Can you answer the
question?
>> No. Like I just don't know. Like I was
it was it written in in in Aramaic or
>> don't it don't matter what it's written
in. Jesus saying that he is the truth.
We agree that even from the Quran
standards, Jesus is claiming to be God.
Right.
>> From like from in that context alone, it
would appear to be so. But like there's
another
>> What do you mean? What do you mean it
appears to be so? But either it is or it
is.
>> No, because there's another person with
a name that had with a name that's one
of the 99 names of Allah. Who is it?
God.
>> Our prophet.
>> Our prophet. Our prophet. Yeah. His name
is Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
And one of the names of Allah is
alhammed. They have the same meaning. So
it doesn't mean necessarily. Alhammed is
the
>> Is Muhammad's name Hmed? You're saying
Hmed, right?
>> Yeah. Al Hamid the praiseworthy.
>> Muhammad is
>> Yeah. Is Ma Muhammad is not Al Hamid, is
it?
>> Muhammad is the praiseworthy.
>> No, that's not what Muhammad means, bro.
It does mean It does mean praiseworthy.
It doesn't mean the praised one, right?
There's a difference.
>> It I can't I can't believe I'm even
defending the Quran. I'm defending
>> We're We're splitting hairs, man.
>> No, we're not. Cuz just like you said,
calling me truthful is not the same as
calling me the truth. Right.
>> Like in that in that context. Yeah.
Yeah. Like but if we didn't have the
context of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam then it would be weird.
>> Would you agree that calling would you
would you agree that calling someone
praiseworthy is different from calling
them the praiseworthy? Right. The
praised one. Right.
>> It it it depends. It depends. It depends
on It depends because Muhammad is a
name. If if for example you go around
calling yourself the praiseworthy
as as your first name, it just sounds
weird.
>> So you have to turn it into a name
because he's still a human.
>> My brother, I I just I just want to know
if we can agree or not. Can we agree
that saying someone is praiseworthy
is different from calling them the
praiseworthy
right
>> in in uh in a con in this context than
in the context of the languages used
I I don't I I I I don't know I don't
know because at the end of the no like
logic no logic listen like Muhammad and
Alamid have the same meaning. And also
>> they don't. No, they don't. See, this is
why this this is what now I like you, S.
I'm not going to lie to you, man. You're
cool. But this is what makes talking to
you guys so tough. It's that you guys
are un you guys it it's so tough for you
guys to be honest with your religion and
because you want to make you want to
make the point and you want to hold on
to a point. So you will you will defy
your religion and defy your common sense
in order to hold on to the point that
the hesitation that you had Sie the
hesitation you had in in when you how
you answered demonstrated the cognitive
battle that was in your mind
>> cognitive dissonance.
>> Can I ask you another question? Just one
more question. Another of the 99 names
of Allah is the King of Kings. Now, if
many rulers in history use that title,
were they claiming to be God? I'm asking
you.
>> Yeah, they were claiming
>> if a ruler says, "I am the king of
kings."
>> Even Christian rulers have said this.
>> Christian rulers have said this where
they claim to be God.
>> New Christian ruler says that, that'll
be blasphemy.
>> The the the Ethiopians claimed it. No,
the what's his name? The uh highly
salassi. He claimed to be the king of
kings.
>> If if they claimed to be the king of
kings, that's blasphemy.
>> That's blasphemy.
>> Yeah,
>> but they're not claiming to be God. He
never claimed to be God. He was a
>> Christian. Yeah, that's that's
blasphemy. If he's claiming to be the
king of kings, that's blasphemy,
brother. That's he's claiming to be God.
>> I would agree it's blasphemy, but it's
not It depends on the way you use it. If
someone like it doesn't necessarily mean
you're claiming to be God but look logic
let me just ask you in the context of
the verses I have provided why do these
verses contradict the gospel of what
Jesus is saying
>> notice how you're switching up I did
notice how you're switching up
everything that you've done we've gotten
to the point now and I need you to
answer this honestly then Jesus claims
to be al hawk we agree that he's
claiming to be God right
>> if Jesus claims to be alak What verse is
that?
>> John 14:6.
>> Oh, John John 14:6. Hold on.
I am the way and the truth and the life.
No one comes to the father except
through me. If Jesus claimed,
if Jesus claimed to, if Jesus said this
and he said that no one comes to the
father except through him, that is a
divine claim.
>> Thank you, brother. So notice none of
this is contradicting what Jesus
teaches. Jesus is teaching that he is
the divine son of the father who is
al-hak the truth the way the only way to
the father and that you cannot get into
heaven except through him you have to
believe in him and look to him for your
eternal life and he's the one who gives
you eternal life he's going to raise you
up on the last day this is Jesus and
what he's teaching there's no way he
taught Islam
>> you know logic you've also admitted John
is a later gospel. In any of the
synoptic gospels,
>> does Jesus call himself the truth?
>> No, not in that way. Why?
>> Cuz I'm of the opinion that you know,
like we Muslims know that the angel was
corrupted.
>> Let me give you something from the
synoptics. As you do the synoptics,
>> who's the king of the day? Who's the
king of the day of judgment?
>> Who is the king of the day of judgment?
I I don't know. Who is it?
>> You don't know?
>> Yeah.
>> Recip Say that again.
>> It's Allah.
>> It's Allah. Yeah, you know the answer to
that. Allah is the king of the day of
judgment. Watch this. We're going to go
to Matthew. Matthew 25. Watch this.
Habibi, wipe those tears away. We're
going to go to Matthew 25. And we're
going to start reading from 31.
>> Matthew 25:31.
All right. Uh when the Son of Man comes
in his glory and all the angels with
him, he will sit on his glorious throne.
>> Now, we know that Jesus is the son of
man, right? That he claims to be.
>> That he claims to be the son of man.
Yeah, he's the son of man.
>> Yeah, I would. Uh, yeah.
>> Good.
>> He does.
>> Now, let's So, Jesus, he says the son of
when the son of man comes in his glory
and all the angels with him, then he
will sit on his glorious throne.
Brother, let me let me ask you before we
get to the cuz I'm about to show you the
really good stuff.
>> Who's the one that's going to come with
the angels, man? According to the Quran,
do you know
>> who's the one who's going to come with
the angels on what day? The day of
judgment.
>> On the day of judgment, brother.
>> I'm not sure. Is it Isaam?
>> Nope. It's Allah.
>> It's Allah.
>> Yep.
>> What? What? Uh, look. Logic.
>> Yes.
>> The son of man is is that's that's from
Daniel, right? It's not necessarily It's
not necessarily God. It's uh the
Messiah.
>> The son of man in Daniel is God along
with the Ancient of Days who sits on the
throne. They both sit on their thrones
and they're and they rule and reign
forever. Uh
>> but h but like how could there be two
kings? Like it doesn't it doesn't make
any sense. Like yeah like logic you know
you're committing you know you're
committing a sherk right now. Like
you're blaspheing how can there be how
can there be two kings?
>> I'm not blaspheming according to the to
the prophets. According to the prophets,
I'm right on target because they teach
that the that they teach that the son of
man in the ancient of days rules
forever. That's what they teach. So, I
mean, I'm right in line with what the
prophets told.
>> What prophets?
>> Daniel, Jesus, you know what I'm saying?
Uh,
>> yeah. But watch this.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Watch this. Watch
this. You ready?
>> All right.
>> All right. So, I'm I'mma actually I'm
going to put show it on the screen so
you don't have to do so much work. I'll
show it on the screen. We're going to go
to chapter 89. Chapter 89 of the Quran
verse uh verse 21 and 22. So 89 verse
21-22.
Watch this.
>> 89 2122.
>> Watch this. Habibi. So watch this. It
says, "Nay, when the earth is ground to
powder and your Lord comes with the
angels in rose,
when the earth is ground to powder,"
that's that's judgment day, right?
That's when Allah comes and wipes
everything away, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And then he look, he says, "And your
Lord comes with the angels in roles." So
on on the judgment day, who's coming
with the angels?
>> Allah.
>> Allah. According to Jesus on judgment
day, who's coming with the angels? It's
right here.
>> The son of man.
>> The son of man. So according to from
even the Quran standards,
who is the son of man?
>> He's God, right?
>> Yo. Yo, Logic, let me ask you a
question. Let me ask you A QUESTION.
>> PER ADVENTURE, SON.
>> NO, NO, NO. Like Logic, let me just ask
one question. Right.
>> Daniel Daniel's Old Testament.
>> No. Per adventure. Per adventure.
Habibi. Answer the question.
>> Like what question? What question?
>> I Okay, I'll ask it again. We already
see that on the last day it's on
judgment day, it's Allah who comes with
the angels. Jesus comes
>> with the angels. Jesus says he's coming
with the angels on judgment day. So
according to the Quran standards, who
does that make Jesus?
>> But the Quran the Quran uh the Quran
never makes this
>> according to the Quran standard when we
read this in the gospel in the synoptic
gospel that Jesus is coming on the day
of judgment with the angels. Who does
that make Jesus even by the Quran
standards?
>> Uh by Okay. by what is being said in
this passage. He's claiming he's you
know he's trying to uh
>> he's claiming that he's
>> he's not actually the one claiming it
though.
>> He is he's speaking it's red letters. So
he's claiming
>> I mean
>> what is he who is he claiming to be?
Answer
>> logic like uh you don't
>> answer
>> like look you you you know what I'm
going to say but
>> uh look fine. He's like he's saying that
in in this context from this verse
>> he's trying like if we look at the
Quranic context
>> Uhhuh.
>> if we look at the Quranic context
alongside the verse
>> Uhhuh.
>> Uh it appears as if he's he's uh he's
claiming to be divine.
>> That's if that's if you ignore the
context. Wait,
>> he said that's if we ignore the context.
Let's
>> No, you know the context of Daniel. Yo,
Logic, let me ask you a question. Daniel
Whoa. Let's keep This was This is just
the tip of the iceberg, brother.
>> No, come on, Logic. Like, it's not fair.
Let me just ask one question. One
question.
>> What do you mean? We're Look, you talked
about the synoptic gospels and that
Jesus never claimed to be God in the
synoptic gospels. So, I'm showing this
to you. Jesus claimed to be God in the
Gnostic Gospels. It gets better. You You
thought that was something? It gets
better. Let's keep reading. Watch. Look.
So, when the Son of Man comes in his
glory and all the angels with him, then
he will sit on his glorious throne.
Before him will be gathered all the
nations, and he will separate the people
from one another as a shepherd separates
the sheep from the goats. And he will
place the sheep on his right and the
goats on his left. You agree this is
judgment day, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Now watch what Jesus calls himself. Then
the king will say to those on his right,
"Come you who are blessed by my father,
inherit the kingdom prepared for you
from the foundation of the world." So
Jesus claims to be the king of the day
of judgment. Right.
>> Yeah.
And according to the Quran, who is the
king on the day of judgment?
>> Uh
Allah.
>> And so by Quranic standards, this means
that Jesus is claiming to be who?
>> Uh he's he's claiming to to be divine.
>> Boom. Boom. So can we agree and I'll let
you go to Daniel right after this. This
is this is the end of it. Can we agree
that the synoptic gospels, not just the
authors themselves, but even Jesus
himself in the synoptic gospels
establish that he's God, that he's
divine? Can we agree with that if we're
honest? in the in the synnotic in the
synoptic gospels like look I look logic
I read the gospels he never said it
explicitly but with these like Quranic
context then then he is claiming that
right but it doesn't refute Islam or it
doesn't mean that he wasn't a Muslim
>> wait wait wait wait you're telling me
that Jesus can teach that he's divine
can
>> no like we don't we don't have to accept
those teachings that's what I'm trying
to tell you did.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. You told
me that the synoptic teachings are the
authentic teachings. THAT'S WHAT YOU
TOLD ME.
>> NO, I I never said that. I said John is
a later gospel. The other three are more
reliable. But like John just John just
goes John just goes completely berserk.
He starts claiming divinity outright
making it.
>> So does so does Mark.
>> Yeah. But like the first three are more
cryptic
uh about their claims and they also have
like the like Mark I I showed you that's
why I showed you those two verses
because they have competing narratives
which show corruption.
>> No, they don't.
>> They do. They have.
>> All right. So, let me ask you this
again. Let me just ask you. Could Jesus
teach these things that we're seeing in
the synoptic gospels? Can he can he say
these things about himself and still be
a Muslim?
>> What things? the things about the the
son of man.
>> Yeah. Him being the son of man who comes
and is the king of the day of judgment
who comes on the day of judgment with
the angels. Can he teach these things
about himself and still be Muslim?
>> He he wouldn't be a Muslim anymore. He
would be he would be what you guys claim
he is. But that's that's what we're
trying to say. The fact that they're
competing narratives in the gospel shows
the corruption that the Quran is talking
about.
>> Yeah. So, um, you hinging on competing
narratives, you haven't demonstrated
that, not in the slightest.
>> Yeah. I I logic you haven't I said those
two verses and you haven't answered
Matthew 19:17 Mark 10:18 where Jesus
says God or in fact let let me look at
it so you don't say I'm paraphrasing
Matthew why do you call me good there's
none good but God alone I already
answered good but God alone what is that
saying
>> that means that Jesus is God that means
that Jesus is God because he's good
again I asked
In what way is God good that Jesus
isn't? Answer. You haven't answered that
yet.
>> Is what? In what way is God good that
Jesus isn't? He's God. He is the
creator.
>> So is Jesus.
>> He's Allah subhanana wa ta'ala. Like
what? Well, he is Allah.
>> What? What way? See, notice you're not
telling me in which ways God is good.
Good. We're talking about God's
holiness, his morality. In which way is
God good? moral, right? Righteous that
Jesus isn't.
>> Well, it's not about really cuz Jesus
was also a moral figure. We we we know
that we accept that we accept that Jesus
figure
>> and we also accept that all the prophets
were good in their own ways like you
understand what I'm saying but this
whole but he's telling his disciple here
and it's not mentioned in one gospel but
two gospels do not say that I am good.
Can you stop? Please don't do that
again. Don't lie in the Bible. He never
says do not say that I'm good. Don't do
that.
>> I can't find says
>> why do you call me good?
>> No one is good but Si
>> you're going to be my last guest because
you're my favorite. But you got you got
to answer the question, bro.
>> In what way is God good?
>> Is God moral? Is God righteous that
Jesus isn't?
>> All right. I'm going to have to ask you.
What do you mean by righteous? Because
Jesus is also righteous.
You don't you don't know what you don't
know what righteous means. Come on. We
know what these verses mean.
>> Because because Jesus is also righteous
>> to be to be good morally morally good
and acceptable. Um holy pure. That's
what righteousness is. What's a what's a
righteous now y'all?
>> So in what way is God good? Moral
righteous. Holy in ways that Jesus
isn't? In what ways is God?
>> In what way is God good, morally good,
that Jesus isn't?
>> Well, uh, in what ways is Jesus good?
Uh, but but but like logic, I'm not the
one saying that he like he I'm trying
I'm trying to say that Jesus is good.
>> I'm asking you.
>> You know what? Let me
>> I'm asking you. I'm asking you. I'm
asking why does he tell his his
disciples not to call him dead?
>> If he doesn't you lied again. He doesn't
he doesn't call him good.
>> Why does he ask his disciples?
>> Notice notice how you can't answer the
question. Matter of fact, do this for
me.
>> In what way is God good that I am not?
In what way is God good that Avery
isn't?
>> In what way are like I I don't know
about your sins, man.
>> Boom.
>> But you have committed sins. That's all
you had to freaking say. You don't know
about my sins. You know I committed them
though, don't you?
>> Yeah.
>> So, you know that I am a flawed sinful
creature while God is pure and perfect
and righteous without sin. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> That is a way that God is good that I am
not. Now, do me this favor. Do the same
do the same thing for Jesus. In what way
is God good that Jesus isn't?
>> In what way is God good that Jesus
isn't? Well, Jesus Well, Jesus didn't he
didn't he didn't sin.
>> So, he's just as good as God, isn't he?
>> So, why does he tell his disciples? Why
is he questioning the disciples here
when they
>> He's not questioning his disciples. is a
rich young ruler with a wrong uh heart
posture coming to Jesus not genuinely.
And so what Jesus does is he tests him
which is why when you keep reading you
see the fulfillment of the test and he
fails miserably. Jesus says keep the
commandments. He says I've done this
from my youth. He says there's one thing
you lack. One thing you lack. Sell all
your things. Give all your things to the
poor and sell them. and then come follow
me. And then the rich man, rich rent
went away sad because he had many
possessions. He loved his possessions
and he didn't want to give them up. Tell
me what commandment was he breaking when
Jesus says
>> what commandment was he breaking?
>> Yeah. When he he chose his possessions
over over Jesus, what what commandment
is he breaking?
>> Uh I don't know like he hadn't done
anything wrong.
>> Let's do this again. So you know in the
context the man chooses to keep his
possessions rather than follow Jesus,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. And so Jesus he asks how do I get
eternal life and Jesus tells him follow
the commandments. You know the
commandments. So he lists the 10. He
names a few out of the 10. So we know in
context Jesus is talking about the ten
commandments. Follow these. He says I've
been doing these from my birth from my
youth. Sorry. Jesus says there's one
that you lack.
Let me
>> let me search the Ten Commandments real
quick.
>> Okay.
>> Ten Commandments. Uh
>> Exodus 20.
>> Yeah. All right. Here they are. I am the
Lord thy God. Thou shalt not take the
name of thy Lord in vain. Keep the
Sabbath day. Honor thou shalt not kill.
Thou shalt not steal. Uh
did he steal from someone or something?
>> No.
>> Did he uh
>> read verse three.
>> Exodus 23. All right. You shall have no
other gods aside from me.
>> You shall have no other gods before me.
>> Right.
>> You should have no other gods before me.
>> When you choose When you choose
something over God, when you love
something over God, you have now made
that thing your God, your idol. His idol
were his possessions. He loved and
cherished his possessions more than he
loved God. And that's what he was
breaking. He was committing idolatry.
That's why Jesus tested him. And that's
why he said, "Give away your possessions
and come follow me." And the man kept
his possessions. He went away sad and
did not follow Jesus. So his heart was
not right. His heart was not right.
Which is why Jesus responds with a
question to him, a thought-provoking
question that tests him. Why do you call
me good? There's none good but God
alone. Do you really believe? Do you
really believe who I am? Who I do? Do
you really believe I'm good? You don't.
Because if you did, you would give away
your possessions and come follow me. Let
me show you that when you came to me
saying, "Good teacher," that it wasn't
sincere. Let me show you that. And Jesus
showed him. He demonstrated it. That his
heart was not sincere. When he called
Jesus good, he didn't mean it. Because
if he did mean it, he would have gave
his possessions up without hesitation
and followed Jesus. Look, yeah, I think
I understand what you're saying about
the parable.
>> Uh,
but my my I still have another question
about the the sin, right? You said that
Jesus is sinless, but he's not the only
sinless figure in the Bible.
>> Well, you know what? We'll talk about
that.
>> We'll talk we'll talk about that next
time. But just to let you know, he is.
We'll we'll talk about that.
>> Wait, what about Adris? We'll we'll talk
about that. Come back. Uh come back
Monday. Come back Monday. We'll
continue. Okay. All
>> right, man. Have a good Have a good one,
bro.
>> You too, bro. You too. Thanks for coming
up, bro.
>> All right, man.
>> Got Si in the house, man. Welcome back,
bro.
>> Hey, Logic. Uh how's it going? I like
our our talk uh on Friday really made me
uh go back and read the Quran cuz it
made me realize that, you know, I've
been slipping. I've been slipping and
you know I don't want to I don't want to
slip anymore. So I'm ready to challenge
you and I'm really convinced that by the
grace of Allah you will take the shahada
one day you will become a Muslim.
>> You just said that you are tired of
slipping and you don't want to be
slipping anymore.
>> Yeah.
>> Let me let me tell you something my new
friend. As long as you have the shahada
over your head
>> and you are professing Muhammad to be a
prophet you will continue to slip.
I'm telling you,
>> look, logic, I
>> come come to Christ, man. Come to Christ
and stand on the solid rock that won't
but it won't crack or fall. You won't be
slipping if you stand on the solid rock.
>> I like you, man. You should you should
embrace.
That's what I feel. Embrace the oneness
of Allah.
>> Doesn't make sense to me, bro. I I I
would embrace it if it made sense to me,
but it doesn't make sense. But like one
God doesn't make sense to you.
>> Tahed is not about one God. It's about
the unification of Allah. All of his
attributes and these things that unify
to make Allah who and what he is. That's
that's what tahed is about. And then
there's problems with that because other
people have attributes that Allah has
and it's just all over the place, man.
Tahed is not clear.
>> But like but the you know the trinity
isn't clear either. Like many people
have issues with the trinity. Like
something being easy to understand
doesn't mean it's correct. You
understand what I'm saying?
>> That's true. You you believe that
Tahhedi makes sense that it's it's
coherent and straightforward, right? Is
that what you believe?
>> I don't believe in just because it makes
sense to me. Like I wouldn't like a lot
of Muslims do this thing where they
reject Christianity based on whether it
makes logical sense to them. They'd say
like even I used to do this before I
started watching uh your content. I used
to say to Christians, I'm like, "Oh, how
can how can God die or how can God be
free?" But like when I've watched more
of your content, I've I've actually
learned not to do this because it's more
complex than that, you know?
>> I I have a better understanding of it
now.
>> That's good. And and I'm I'm saying that
that tal I'm I'm not not saying that
it's it's I'm just it's false because
it's it's not coherent. doesn't it's not
consistent. You know that that's what
I'm saying. I'm saying you you want me
to embrace but there's problems with
so I can't embrace it. Oh,
>> we'll see man. We'll see. Well, look,
this Messiah thing um I I didn't really
understand the question, but I think I I
get what you're trying to say now. But I
have two questions, Logic. Two
questions. And it goes back to what you
were saying to the other guys who are
here. The first one is about Isaiah 14.
Like the first one I I don't know why
you bring up that verse about Isaiah 14
because doesn't it contradict
Christianity? I was I was like screaming
at the screen when I saw that. I
couldn't believe that was in the Bible
because it says his name is Emanuel.
>> Before we go,
>> it's not Jesus's name.
>> Yeah, that that is one of his names. But
before before we go, did you see my
debate with uh with Junior
>> with No, look, I've actually not watched
it, but like Junior's not he's not a
good representative of of Islam.
>> So like come on, man. Like he's not
really I'm not trying to insult them,
but he's not very uh he's not very
intelligent. Like they're better guys.
Like they're better guys, man. Like I
was actually a bit disappointed to to to
even see that cuz I I I know how it's
going to end. So like I'm not I'm not
really going to watch it.
>> Okay. But maybe he did good. You don't
know. I I I I've seen I've actually seen
his his other debates like he had one
with what's the name of that guy with
the
>> IP inspiring philosophy.
>> Yeah. And he starts talking about his
his Hebrew uh tattoo.
>> It's just low IQ stuff, man. We're just
embarrassing the Umar. He's making us
look bad. So,
>> I just I've actually sent him DMs,
begging him to stop. Like, he makes us
look bad because like he takes he
debates everyone without like care for
how bad it looks and he doesn't do the
work. Like I I He's not a good
representative of of Islam. There are
better guys, man. Trust me.
>> I I hear you. Well, there's a lot of
people in the chat right now saying W
Jr., You know,
>> W Jun, what do you mean?
>> Like like like he's he's awesome.
>> Oh, are they are they Muslims?
>> No, they're it looks like they're
Christians saying W Jr.
>> They're making fun of him, right?
>> And no, like W like Yay Junior. They're
like rooting for him.
>> They're rooting for him.
>> Yes, they're rooting for him.
>> Yeah, because of him. Like in our
debate, um there was a a girl. She uh
she was a Muslim and she decided to
leave Islam because of the debate. like
that was the last straw for her. She's
she's been on this this channel before.
She came, she was a Muslim, she was
asking questions and inquiring and then
saw that debate and that was the last
straw for her. She was like, "Yeah,
because of how dishonest Junior was and
I'm seeing the flaws, I I'm leaving
Islam. This is this is it for me."
>> Yeah. Cuz look, this is what this is
what like a bad debate can do. Can
actually push people away from the dean.
This is why like I told him, you are
actively sending people to Janam. Stop
debating people. You're embarrassing the
dean. You're sending people to hell.
>> It's It doesn't make any sense cuz
you're not winning these debates unless
you're completely deluded.
>> Like, you're not winning these debates,
man. That IP one, I just had to turn it
off midstream was just it was just it
was just not I just didn't like that at
all.
>> I hear you. All right. Well, I just
wanted to hear your opinion on on the
guy. So, what uh
>> the second Yo, but my second question,
right? Sorry. The second question was
regarding the the guy who just came on
like with the accent.
>> I thought you wanted to talk about
Emanuel.
>> Yeah, I know. I have two questions,
right? The second one is for that guy. I
just wanted to explain his point of view
a bit, right? Cuz there's like there's a
weak hadith, a weak one,
>> that talks about Allah sending
124,000 prophets to the nations. I don't
know if you've heard of that.
>> Yeah, I've heard of that. Yeah.
>> So, yeah, that's probably what he's
talking about. So even in Islamic
history there was a time of like where
the Muslims were in charge of India and
they they actually were collecting Jiza
from the Hindus even though they're not
supposed to because you know they're not
people of the book. They're not
>> but they were collecting Jiza from them
because the they they used that hadith
and said oh the Hindus there's some
things in the Hindu scriptures which are
correct. So obviously they distorted
some of their their prophets words. You
get what I'm saying? So like I'm just
trying to explain his point of view. But
like even there's also like in
Christianity some also there's some like
endorsement of of of Zoroastrianism as
well.
>> There's there's no there's no uh
endorsement of any heresies. None.
>> Do do you know why I say that? Because
>> Well, wait before cuz we're getting off
now. I I want to get to the to the meat
of the issue, man. I want to get to the
topic.
>> All right, man.
>> So, the uh the Messiah thing, man. The
Messiah thing. And you say that
>> the Messiah,
>> you think that Isaiah
>> Isaiah 14
>> Isaiah 7:14 contradicts what I'm saying?
>> Oh, 7 Oh, yeah. 7:14. Yeah. Sorry, I
didn't write it down. Well, yeah. 7:14.
It says his name is Emmanuel. And then
so you Christians interpret this as the
translation of you guys interpret uh
Emmanuel as the translation of of the of
Emmanuel into English. But
>> that's not how I inter interpret it. I
don't interpret it as that. How I
interpret it is how it says it. Right.
If you want to get the correct
interpretation, the correct
interpretation is just looking at what
the Hebrew What's funny?
>> What's funny? It was funny, Sally.
>> Nothing. Nothing, man. Nothing. Nothing.
>> Okay. Okay. Don't Don't make fun of how
I say things. All right. Don't be
laughing at me. So, if you want to get
the right interpretation,
you look at what the Hebrew word is and
you can interpret by what it says. And
it says Emmanuel is literally God with
us. That's what it means. So then when
we go to the New Testament and interpret
the New Testament, sorry in interpret
the New Testament, we see that he's
directly identified as the Emanuel who's
supposed to be born of a virgin.
>> He's ident. But yet my issue with the
the verse is that it's not his name.
Jesus's name is not Emmanuel. Like show
me any place.
>> That's I'll show you right now. I'mma
show you right now. This is one of his
names, man.
>> All right. Show me.
>> Hold on. Let me let me I got you, bro.
Here we go. Here we go. Watch this hill.
Watch this hill. Okay. This is Matthew
chapter 1 verse I'll do uh 21 and 23.
She will bear a son and you shall call
his name Jesus. For he will save his
people from their sins. All this took
place to fulfill what the Lord had
spoken by the prophet. Behold, the
virgin shall conceive and bear a son,
and they shall call his name Emmanuel,
which means God with us. So, Matthew
directly applies this prophecy and says
that Jesus is Emmanuel.
>> Yeah. Look, I like Matthew is applying
this prophecy to show that Jesus is born
of a virgin. his like unless the only
way I would accept this if you say Jesus
and Emmanuel have the same meaning then
I'll be like okay fine that's that's
what Matthew is trying to do but Jesus
and Emanuel do not have the same
meaningual
>> I agree with you Jesus and Emanuel are
two different words with two different
meanings my point is is that both apply
to him you're you're saying that just
because he's named Jesus that that
nullifies that he's also named Emanuel
no he has multiple names Man, Emanuel is
one of them, which is why Matthew
applies this to him. Can Can we agree
that Matthew applies the name Emanuel to
Jesus?
>> I can we agree that they Matthew applies
it to him. He says they shall call him
Emmanuel.
>> Mhm. So Jesus is saying behold the
virgin shall conceive. He said all this
took place to fulfill what the Lord has
a prophet.
>> Yeah. In the previous verse, the angel,
is it an angel that's speaking to Mary,
or who is who speaking to Mary?
>> Yeah, it's an angel.
>> It's an angel. So, the angel says uh to
Mary, you shall call his name Jesus. You
shall call his name Jesus, not Emmanuel.
>> You name him.
>> What the prophecy says is the people
shall call him Emmanuel, God with us.
>> Oh, it just it just says, "Behold, and
they shall call his name."
>> Call his name Emmanuel.
>> So, is is Matthew applying ma Emmanuel
to Jesus?
>> Yeah. Yeah. In this context. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, you you asked me for a New
Testament reference where Jesus is
called Emmanuel. Matthew literally does
it in the beginning of his gospel.
>> Yeah. But that's like that's what they
that's how do you say it's retroactive.
There are many
>> you can say that you can say it's
retroactive. But remember you asked me
for where in the New Testament is Jesus
identified at as Emanuel. I just showed
this to you. And not only this, but if
you look into early church, the early
church history and writings and even the
songs and hymns that's written about
Jesus, he's continuously called Emmanuel
by the believers. He's he's called
Emanuel to this day.
>> He's You guys call him Emmanuel?
>> Yeah. We have songs that literally call
him Emanuel, bro. There's one there's
one song that uh that we used to sing in
my my in my dad's church. It would it
would go Emmanuel.
Emmanuel. We're calling him Emmanuel.
Emmanuel. You know, so there's a lot of
songs of worship and hymns directed to
Jesus calling him Emmanuel. There's
Look, uh yeah, I'm I'm not familiar with
that because like I always know Emmanuel
is a given name, right? Like not really
a name of Jesus because like you
Christians don't really give Jesus as a
given name apart from like Spanish
people, right? Like I I don't see people
being called like Jesus. It's rare.
>> Okay. I I don't know what that has to do
with anything really, but I'm just
saying Jesus is identified as Emmanuel
directly in the New Testament and by
believers that followed through
generations even to this day and people
are named Emmanuel.
>> Yeah. That's that's what I'm saying is
that like like Christians don't usually
give names of Jesus to their children.
That's what I'm trying to say.
>> That's not true. That's not true at all.
people people are named Jesus. People
are called Emanuel. What you mean?
>> Yeah, that's what I'm saying. Like apart
from like Spanish people, but like I
didn't know that you guys used the name
uh Emanuel for Jesus. Like like I said,
like I saw it when we were talking to to
that dude and like I was just shocked
cuz like Jesus's name is not Emanuel.
That was the first time I read about it.
>> Well, now you know. Yeah. Now you know.
>> I'm I'm I'm going to do I'm going to do
more I'm going to do more research on
that, right? about the whole Emanuel
thing, right?
>> Sure. Sure.
>> But the second thing is that like the
whole G uh Christianity affirming
Zoroastrianism because you guys that's
not the topic, bro. The topic is about
Jesus being the Messiah in Islam and how
do you prove that? That's the topic.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Look, I agree with
that. It's just that like you were you
were writing down the stuff that the guy
before you said like and I and I know it
sounded dumb but like it's kind of like
like hypocrisy about
>> calling him out from the back of
>> brother we're past that. I want to know
>> all right
>> how
>> you want to know why Jesus is the
Messiah.
>> I want to know why Jesus is the Messiah.
Why is he the Messiah in Islam?
>> Jesus is the Messiah. He's the last
Nabi. He's his last prophet sent to the
people of Banu, Israel. He's the
>> final one.
>> I'm confused because
wasn't Muhammad sent to Benny Israel
too?
>> No, he was sent to the whole world.
>> So that includes Ben Israel, right?
>> Yeah. But Jesus was the final one sent
to Banu Israel like directly like like
Muhammad like uh he was sent to the
people of Banu Israel only. You get what
I'm saying? He was
>> No, he he wasn't sent to them only.
>> Like he was sent to the people of Ben
Israel only. It was the last
>> Where does the Where does the Quran say
that he was sent only to Israel?
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on.
>> Oh, I know the verse you're thinking of.
Uh chapter 19 verse uh verse 21 is is
where is what you're looking for?
>> 19 21.
>> Yeah.
>> Let me let me search that up real quick.
>> Quran Yeah. Quran 19:21.
>> Yeah, that's the one you're looking for.
Surah Sarah Mariam.
>> Sarah Mariam ayat 21.
>> Yeah. So will it be? Your Lord says it
is easy for me. And so we will make him
a sight. Aha. Very funny.
>> Go ahead. Read it out.
>> Very funny. Very funny. You know what?
You know what? Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait.
>> Read it.
>> No, I agree. I agree. It's a sight to
the people. I agree. It's a sight to the
people.
>> Read it out loud.
>> So the last No, hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. Read it. Ikra,
>> wait, wait, wait, wait.
>> Ra,
>> wait, wait, hold on, hold on, hold on.
>> Ra, read it.
>> No, hold on, hold on. I mean, he's the
last prophet sent that lived amongst the
people of Banu Israel, but he's also was
signed to the people. How do you know?
>> He's the last one sent to the to live
amongst them.
>> So, the verse
>> in Israel, he was in the in the land of
Israel. I never going to say that.
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Where does
your Quran say that? Where does your
Quran say that Jesus lived in Israel?
>> What?
>> Where does your Quran say that? That he
lived in Israel?
>> Where does the Quran say that?
>> Yeah.
>> Like why does the Quran have to say
that?
>> Because you just made the claim.
>> You just made the claim that he was the
last prophet who lived in Israel. Where
do you get that from?
>> If like does it say he doesn't live in
Israel? He doesn't say that. Like we
know he lives in Israel.
>> How how do you know? That's what I'm
asking. How do you know that? is the
Quran.
>> I know what you want me to say. You want
me to say
>> I want you to say
>> I know what you want me to say.
>> SAY THE TRUTH, BABY. JUST say the truth.
Where you get that from?
>> Okay. There are there are sources
outside the Quran that say
>> like what?
>> Like what? Si
historical sources.
>> Si
>> Josephus
>> Josephus says that Jesus lived in
Israel.
>> He lived in Palestine land of Israel at
the time.
>> Who says that? Where you
>> Josephus says that. Where does Josephus
say Jesus? Where does Okay, so just to
be clear, so Josephus is where we get
historical information about Jesus. Is
that right?
>> Yeah, Josephus is is a reliable source.
There are other sources, but I'm not I'm
not going to mention them.
>> It's okay.
>> I'm not going to give you the
satisfaction.
>> Wait, wait, wait. I'm I'm just curious.
Out of curiosity, and we can stick with
Josephus, but out of curiosity, what are
those other sources? I'm not going to
say it cuz like I know what you're
trying I know what you're trying to do.
>> You are being upon the hawk. The truth,
right?
>> I'm upon the hawk. Yes, I am on the
hawk.
>> Does the hawk hide?
>> Look. Okay, fine. You know what? The
Bible also says that. But you know, you
know, it doesn't even matter, right? But
it doesn't wait. Why do you even Okay,
wait. Hold on. the the the Quran accepts
that like like Jesus was sent to the
people of of of you know what Jesus was
sent to the people of of Banu Israel in
Palestine. We know that from the
scriptures.
>> I can I can give you that. I can give
you that Jesus was sent to the people of
Israel. However, what I will not allow
you to conclude is
concluding that Jesus is only sent to
Israel. Right? That's why I won't let
you do it because we you just read a
verse that Jesus is a sign and a mercy
for mankind, for the people, not just
Israel.
>> But his main mission is to Israel. Look
at Quran 3:15.
>> I Hey, I can grant you that. I can grant
you that his main mission, his priority
was Israel, but that doesn't mean that
he was limited or isolated to Israel. He
was also for everyone else, too. Can we
>> No, he was assigned He was assigned to
everyone else because he was also
assigned to the people because of his
his uh his conduct.
>> Yep.
>> His message, his conduct, his life.
Absolutely. I'm I'm
>> his life. He was assigned to the people
in just his whole life was a miracle,
right? because he was born of a
>> of a virgin. It was a sign from from
God.
>> You preaching right now, man. Okay.
>> But we we we love Jesus as well. I don't
know why you guys deny that. We love
>> We deny it because you deny who he is.
You can't say you love Jesus and deny
who he is. That's that's like saying
that you love your mother, but you deny
that she's your mother. That's not love.
See, you get it? So, look, let's So,
staying on track. So Jesus is the
Messiah and you're saying because he was
sent to Israel. Is that what you're
saying? That's why that's what makes him
the Messiah.
>> Yeah. Because Messiah is a Jewish is uh
pardon me. It's a Hebrew word. The
anointed one. He is the final one sent
to them. He's telling them, he's giving
he's the f because Jesus uh sorry,
pardon me. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
telling the Jews, stop changing your
scriptures. Stop selling the scriptures
and doing all these corrupt things.
>> Pause there. Pause there. Pause there.
So, if I'm interpreting what you're
saying correctly is that Jesus is the
Messiah because he's the final messenger
and prophet to Ben Israel. Is that
correct?
>> He is the they live they live because
Allah gave them favor. He gave Ben
Israel favor. But he that's fine and all
just
>> after after Jesus after Jesus it becomes
through through the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam it becomes a
universalized
message to the whole world because they
have given the prophets
>> I'm lost because Jesus can't be the
final the final prophet and messenger to
Ben Israel to ch to the children of
Israel if another prophet was coming
after him to not just been Israel but
everyone else as well. So he's not the
final messenger and prophet to Israel.
Muhammad would be
>> well Jesus comes back again.
>> Yeah, he's actually he is he's coming
back to kill the the the Jalins and uh
abolish the Jizian and kill the pigs. So
he is coming back but he is the final
one to ban Israel. Not not uh ex the
final ones Israel exclusively, right? He
lived amongst them.
>> I'm confused because Muhammad also lived
among the children of Israel.
>> No, but he you know what I'm saying?
Like he we just established that Jesus
lived in in Israel. He lived in
Palestine.
>> So, but that's not what you're saying.
That's not what you're saying. You're
saying
>> No, I'm saying that Okay, fine. Uh he
he's the final one in Palestine. He's
the final one to be in the in Jerusalem
for the ban of Israel.
>> Okay,
>> you understand what I'm saying?
>> I got you. So, he's the final one to
actually be in the land of Israel
>> dealing with Israel in the land.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. So where do
you get it from? That a criteria, a
requirement of the Messiah is to be the
final messenger who lives in Israel
among the Israelites. Where do you get
that from?
>> Where do I get that from? The criteria
of the Messiah. Uh I mean, we probably
have to go to the Hadith or the Torah.
>> The Hadith or the Torah.
Go ahead. Show me. Show me anywhere. I
mean, show me something that says that
that's what that's what, you know, the
Messiah is supposed to be, the final
prophet and messenger who lives in
Israel among the Israelites.
>> Well, I mean, the the the the
way the Jews view the Messiah, I'm just
talking about the the the the way Jews
view him. They actually view him as a
ruler. Like, it's not he they don't see
him as as the the as they both they
reject Jesus. Like so they don't see him
as a prophet. They see him as a ruler.
You guys see him as God. So the everyone
has a different view of what the Messiah
is. The Islamic view.
>> That don't that's not dealing with what
I'm asking, bro. I'm asking
>> when you say that Jesus is the Messiah
because he was the last and final
messenger and prophet living among
living in the land of Israel among the
Israelites. Where do you get that? That
right there is a checkbox for being the
Messiah. Like when you have
characteristics of let's say we had a
list of characteristics of the Messiah,
what the Messiah is supposed to be, what
he's supposed to do. Where do you get it
from that being the last messenger among
that lives in the land of Israel with
the Israelites is part of the list?
Well, uh it's there, uh there are other
there there are other things in Jesus's
life that showed you the Messiah. Like
he's a he's born of a virgin as well.
But like if we're talking,
>> are we abandoning the first reason you
gave and we're going to the virgin part?
>> The first the first the first reason is
more of like intuitive reasoning from
me. Like he I'm just
>> So you So you made it up.
>> It's it's not I'm just reasoning, man.
Because like you're like it's the best
way to to to examine your question,
right? Because you're asking us like why
do we think he's the Messiah? And it's a
Jewish child. So it's not really No, no,
no, no, no. You're getting me wrong. I'm
not asking why why you think he's the
Messiah. I'm asking why is he the
Messiah objectively? Because your Quran
says he's the Messiah. So basically, I'm
asking you guys to prove it. What makes
him the Messiah? Give me the reasons
that make him the Messiah so that we
know that the Quran got this right.
That's that's what it is.
>> We can we can we both agree that one of
the criteria
is that he's born of a virgin, right?
>> Where would you get that from?
>> From the from from the Jewish
scriptures, right?
>> Boom. And where do we find in the Jewish
scriptures that the Messiah is supposed
to be born of a virgin?
>> Where do we find that in the Jewish
script? I'm I'm not sure.
>> I you I showed it earlier, bro. 714.
714. Remember?
>> Oh, 714. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, I'm with you on that.
I'm with you. One of the requirements is
that the Messiah is to be born of a
virgin. And
>> according to what it says about the
Messiah being born of a virgin, what
does it identify him as? Emmanuel,
meaning God with us. Right. Right.
>> Look.
>> Right.
>> Uh, wait, wait, wait. Logic. Let's wait.
Let's go back. Let's go back. Can we go
back?
>> No, no, NO, NO, NO, NO. NO, NO, NO, NO.
I'm I'm No, I I I promise you. I promise
you. I I swear I swear I swear to God. I
am not I'm not I'm not wiggling. I
promise. I promise. I I didn't actually
see the verse. Well,
>> hey, no.
>> Come. No. No. I actually didn't see the
verse. Well, I'm serious. Come on. Wait.
Go back. Go back. I didn't see it. Well,
I want to read it out. I want to read it
out so I can show you something I saw.
I'm being serious. No. Wait. Come on,
man. Wait. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Logic. Wait. Wait, go back. I want to
show you something in the verse. I want
to show you something in the verse
because it's completely different from
what Matthew says. Like there's a key
difference.
>> I I'll I'll give you I'll give you a
chance to reread it. But first, I need
you to answer this for me, okay? And
then I'll let you break it. Whatever.
See whatever you want to see. Deal.
>> Yeah, no problem. Yeah, no problem.
According
to the the
prophecy about the Messiah being born of
a virgin, can we agree that it
identifies him as God with us?
>> It identifies his name as God with us.
There's no doubt about that.
>> Okay. And do you believe that Jesus is
God with us?
>> Do I believe that Jesus is God with us?
That's sharp. I can't I can't say that.
>> Exactly. And so this is what my point is
is that you
>> Let me let me just read Let me show you.
I'm I'm about to land this point and
then I'm going to let you do your thing.
Okay,
>> this is the point. The point is is that
when the Quran
and Muslims acknowledge that Jesus is
the Messiah, you guys are committing
sherk because the Messiah is identified
as God with us. If you're saying that
Jesus is the Messiah, you're saying that
Jesus is God with us and therefore Islam
is false and collapses. So that's the
point. Now, I'll let you I'll put it on
the screen so you can uh do your thing.
You know what I'm saying?
>> Look, logic, I should get I get your
reasoning, but let's read this verse
carefully.
>> Okay.
>> Therefore, the Lord himself will give
you a sign. Behold, the virgin shall
conceive and bear a son, and shall call
his name Emmanuel. Now, if we go to what
Matthew said, Matthew said, you shall
call his name Jesus, and the people
shall call his name,
>> it says they,
>> Emmanuel.
>> They shall call his name Emmanuel.
Sorry.
>> But here it says that the virgin shall
call his name Emmanuel. Now, logic, my
question to you, where does Mary call
her son Emmanuel? If you can show me
that, I will become a Christian right
now.
>> Okay. So, Sully, this is a this is a
tough way to try to get away from this.
>> HOW AM I GOING to get away? It's a
>> I'm about to tell you, bro. I'm about to
tell you. Okay. This says, "Behold, the
virgin shall conceive and bear a son,
and shall call his name Emmanuel."
And you're saying that in Matthew it
says, "They shall call his name
Emmanuel." So show me where Mary called
Jesus Emmanuel. So if there let me ask
you this. If there is not a verse an
explicit verse where Mary calls Jesus or
identifies Jesus Emmanuel or God with
us, does that mean that she never did
that?
>> No logic, right? The the the angel says
you shall call his name Jesus, right?
And it says they shall call his name
Emmanuel.
>> That's not what I asked.
>> These are two different names.
>> That's not what I asked, brother.
>> What?
>> I'll ask it again. If we don't have a
record of Mary verbatim calling Jesus
Emmanuel, does that mean that she never
called him Emanuel?
>> No, it doesn't mean that. It doesn't
mean that at all.
>> So, I don't need to show you a verse
where Mary verbatim calls him Emanuel if
she identifies.
>> You don't you don't even need you don't
even need to show me that. You don't
need to show me that because let me even
rephrase this because I'm seeing people
in the chat saying like exact word
fallacy because like this is a specific
request, right? If you can show me where
the angel says just the angel says you
call him to Mary, you call him Emanuel.
>> Name him Emanuel.
>> Why does it have to be that? Why?
>> Because the angel specifically says you
shall call him Jesus. That means
theologically the name Jesus serves a
purpose.
>> I agree. The name Jesus means God is God
of salvation. So
>> exactly.
>> So So
>> hold on. I'm I'm just I agree with you.
Jesus I already said this. Jesus and
Emanuel are two different words, two
different names. Both apply to Jesus.
Both of them. And we already saw that.
Okay. So we already saw that Mary having
a son and even naming him Jesus is the
is the fulfillment of Isaiah 7:14
when he the virgin is conceiving of the
son and he will be called Emmanuel. The
people call him Emmanuel. Matthew
identified him as Emanuel. Believers in
generations past call him Emmanuel. We
call him Emanuel to this day. We all
ident we don't even have to call him say
the word Emmanuel. We identify him as
God with us. You identify Jesus as God
in the flesh. God with us. You're
identifying him as Emmanuel in meaning.
So I I don't this this argument isn't
isn't a good argument. Dude, logic.
Logic. Last time last time I came here,
we were very specific, right? Because
when I I I I accepted when you said that
al-Hak the truth is different from
truthful and um Muhammad is different
from Alhame. I I accepted that cuz my
wording matters. Isaiah 7:14 is saying
the virgin shall call him Emmanuel as
well. Right now if you're saying that
Mary could have called him that but we
don't have evidence of it that's fine.
But you guys are the ones when we say
that the inje is a book given to Jesus.
And you ask yourself, so how do we know
that? You ask, how do we know that? We
say, "Oh, we don't have the book with
us." You guys make fun of us. You say,
"Oh, that's crazy. How can you how can
you uh how can you make this claim?" So,
I can accept your reasoning. I can
accept your logic about about Mary. We
don't know what she said. Peace be on
her. We don't know what she said. But if
you can make the same leeway for us when
we talk about the inje that's fair. If
you can say that oh we don't know what
the inje given to Jesus was that's
that's that's fair.
>> Okay. There's two different things here.
Number one we have a scriptural basis of
what Emanuel means and the belief behind
it. Believing that Jesus is God with us.
Mary believed that her son is the savior
of the world. I.e. being the divine
savior that she was given birth to. And
we see that the New Testament, we see
that Matthew identifies Jesus as Emanuel
or God with us and how that is
fulfilling that prophecy. We have
textual basis for what we're saying. You
have no textual basis. You have no basis
at all for saying that the angel that
the angel that the Quran is talking
about is not Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John. You have nothing to basis for.
>> We have text. We have a textual basis
for that because the Quran is clear that
the scripture was given to Jesus by God
directly.
>> Okay? Okay. And the Quran is very clear
that that same scripture given to Jesus
is in the possession of the Jews, Jews
and Christians, right?
>> It's in possession not in the sense
you're thinking it's in possession in
the abstract cuz like there are things
in the Bible that are true.
>> No, it says I'm sorry. It says that the
gospel is written and with with the
Christians that they have possession of
it. A written document.
>> Wait, hold on. Pull up the verse,
please.
>> I got you. Chapter 7 verse 157. It says
that those who follow the unlettered
prophet who can neither read nor write.
I'm going pull it up for you. Whom they
find written in the Torah and gospel
with them. Let me pull that up for you.
7157.
>> They he who commands them only those who
>> Oh, you see it. See it?
>> Yeah, I see it. They are the ones who
follow the messenger, the unleted
prophet, whose description they find in
the Torah and the gospel. But
>> to be clear, the word description there,
cuz I just want to be as clear as I can.
The word description there is not it's
not that's a that's the wrong
translation. The word is maktubin, which
literally means written. If you want, I
can
>> Yeah. Uh I actually don't speak uh
Arabic.
>> Yeah, I'll take your word for it, man.
>> Yeah, it's right here on the screen. I
just pulled up the Arabic corpus. Maktum
>> written.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. Uh yeah, let's could we uh go back
to 157?
>> Yeah.
>> And uh those who follow the messenger,
the prophet who can neither read nor
write i.e. Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam whom they find written with
them in the Torah and the in
he commands them. Notice how the
commentary now I don't really go with
commentaries but because I don't like
people adding to the verses but notice
how the commentary even quotes what we
have quotes the gospel of John and it
quotes
>> John 14 is is does the does John what
does John 14:16 say about the prophet?
>> It doesn't say anything about the
prophet. It says it's talking about
where Jesus says that he's going to send
the comforter or the father's going to
send the comforter in his name. The
spirit of truth. Oh, the par the
paraclete.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, that's the paraclete verse. Yeah,
that's that's that's a bad seir.
>> I know.
>> How about uh Deuteronomy?
>> That's 185.
>> 18:15. Yeah. What does that say?
>> The prophet like Moses.
>> Oh, the prophet like Moses. Yeah. I
mean, that's more plausible.
>> That's horrible, too, because it has to
be an Israelite.
>> Could Where could you pull you pull that
up?
>> Sure. Uh
It's gone. The Lord your God will raise
up for you a prophet like me from among
you. From your brothers. It is to him
you shall listen. So he has to be an
Israelite. from among your from your
brother. I mean the people of Ishmael
are also their brothers technically.
>> Nope, not really. From among you from
your brothers or Israelites brother. It
says the same thing about picking a
king. Choosing a king for Israel. It
says from among your brothers, not a
foreigner. So anyone who's not from
among their brothers is a foreigner to
Israel. That means they're has to be an
Israelite. It says that where
>> in Deuteronomy 17 it talks about how
about them picking a king when they were
asking for a king and God says you may
pick a king from one from among your
brothers. You shall not pick a foreigner
who is not from among who is not your
brother meaning so their brothers are
the Israelites from among them from
among your brothers means the
Israelites.
>> Um
>> want to see the verse?
>> Uh yeah sure why not.
>> Okay.
You may indeed set a king over you whom
the Lord your God will choose. One from
among your brothers you shall set as
king over you. You may not put a
foreigner over you who is not your
brother. Did Israel ever have a
non-Israelite king?
>> I'm not sure about that. I don't know.
>> The answer the answer is no, brother.
Every king of Israel was an Israelite
and it's because of this.
How about the this the Samaritans?
>> They weren't they weren't they weren't
kings,
>> were they? Look look Ro lo I I have to
look like I said I'm going to do
research on these on these verses right
but I mean I have heard from shakes that
uh the prophet is mentioned in in your
gal.
>> Yeah that's that's that's the first
that's the first place you went wrong is
you heard from shakes. That's the first
>> Yeah. Like I said, I'm I'm going to do
my own research. He might not be
mentioned uh by name.
>> By name, he's not mentioned by
description. He's not mentioned at all.
>> Yeah, but yeah, he's not mentioned he's
not mentioned uh he's not mentioned
>> at all. Say with me,
>> yeah, he's not mentioned in the Bible,
but the uh the Quran says that, you
know, Jesus speaks of him. He he names
him.
>> And that's the problem. Sali, the Quran
says that Jesus mentioned Ahmed by name.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. But his uh write it down. Like his
disciples didn't write it down. That's
the
>> No, he never said he he How do you know?
>> How do I know? I'll tell you how I know.
Because Jesus revealed the gospel to the
disciples, right? And then he says that
I'm going to give you the Holy Spirit
and the Holy Spirit is going to bring
remembrance of everything that I taught
you and lead you into all the truth. So
when the disciples Yes. So when the
disciples are giving the gospel, they
are recounting perfectly through the
Holy Spirit by inspiration of the Holy
Spirit what Jesus taught. And he never
ever taught about nobody named Ahmed.
Matter of fact, he taught the opposite.
>> But like logic, right? There's there's
uh there if the disciples were guided by
God like you claim, why are there like
inongruencies in the gospels?
>> Did you say inongruencies?
>> Yeah. Inongruencies like you know
>> like narratives that don't match up. the
the way the the way that I interpret
what you're saying is that you're saying
that there's contradictions between the
gospel accounts and there's not
>> Yeah.
>> So
>> like like the the gospels can't even get
what Jesus said on the cross right.
Well, let's let's talk about let's talk
about that next time because if that's
what you identify as a as a
contradiction, we're going to have a fun
time with, you know, with that theme and
see and and how the Quran depicts this
the narratives that it talks about in
different chapters about the same story.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Look, logic. Yeah. Look,
this was uh was a good conversation. I'm
definitely gonna look up I'm gonna look
up a lot of this stuff that you're
saying that about the the uh about the
prophet. Uh I'm gonna talk to my shakes
as well about the where he um I'm going
to I'm just going to research it, but I
would be surprised if he's not uh what
do you think about Daniel 2?
>> I think that Daniel 2
destroys Islam theologically and
historically. And you have to commit
sherk to say that Daniel 2 is about the
advent of Islam.
>> Wait, why?
>> Because the king of the fifth kingdom is
the son of man who is glorified and
rules along the ancient side the ancient
of days and is also called the most high
in Daniel 7. Those those two go hand in
hand. So to say that and and obviously
the Quran says that Allah has no partner
in his kingdom and in his dominion. Yet
Daniel 2 and Daniel 7 show that the son
of man is a companion in authority and
rulership with the ancient of days. So
it'll be sherk by Quranic standards.
>> Um could I could I quickly see the verse
before I I leave?
>> Of course.
>> Of course. Let me show I I'll show you
what the Quran says and then I'll show
you what I'll show you side by side.
Okay, let me see what is chapter 17.
Hold on. Let me get the verse. Let me
let me get the verse. Yes, indeed.
Indeed. Indeed. Okay. So, if we open up
the the Quran, we're going to get the
Quran. We're going to go to to surah
surel
chapter 17 verse 111. And we going to
get the truth out of this. All right.
So, this is what it says. and say, "All
the praises and thanks be to Allah." All
of it, right? All the praises and thanks
be to Allah. Who has not begotten a son
and who has no partner in his dominion
nor he is low to have a wall I guess
helper.
>> Okay. And magnify him with all the
magnificent magnificence. Okay. Pretty
clear, right? So Allah has no partner in
his dominion in his kingdom. Right now
watch this. I'm going to go to Daniel
chapter 2. Let's do what is it? 44. Is
it 44? Let's Let's do 44 real quick.
Yeah. She'll stand forever. All right.
What is What is 40 46? Just as you saw
guys may know. Okay. Okay. Yep. Okay.
Okay. And then we'll do Daniel 7. Let's
do 13 to 14. All right. You with me? so
far.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. All right. So it says
>> like just talking about the uh Quranic
the Quranic verse Allah Allah actually
does uh have used the use the term wi in
in Quran 555 but uh
>> for himself
>> for himself for as he says that the the
prophet will also be a wing for for uh
for the believers.
>> Okay. So their their their helpers or
protections or whatever is for the
believers, not Allah.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. So I I wouldn't say that that's a
problem. Okay. You ready for you ready
for the verse? Now remember the
important part here is about not having
a partner in his dominion. Okay. He has
no companion in his in his dominion in
his rule. Right? So Daniel chapter 2,
and in the days of those kings, the God
of heaven will set up a kingdom that
shall never be destroyed, nor shall the
kingdom be left to another people. It
shall break in pieces all these kingdoms
and bring them to an end, and it shall
stand forever. Just as you saw that a
stone was cut from a mountain by no
human hand, and it and that it broke in
pieces the iron, the bronze, the clay,
the silver, and the gold. All right. So
we see that this is the kingdom. This
fifth kingdom is going to last forever
is it'll never be destroyed. Right? And
it shall stand forever. Right? Now this
is the same kingdom that the son of man
rules. Watch. I saw in the night visions
and behold with the clouds of heaven
there came one like a son of man. And he
came to the ancient of days and was
presented before him. and to him was
given dominion and glory and a kingdom
that all peoples, nations, and languages
should serve him. His dominion is an
everlasting dominion which shall not
pass away and his kingdom one that shall
not be destroyed.
>> So this is the kingdom of God in Daniel
2. And the one who rules the is the son
of man. So for uh Daniel 2:4 and5,
are you are you saying that Jesus
established the kingdom?
>> Not yet. He will. He will. He'll do that
when he returns. Right. So the son of
man is the one who rules the kingdom of
God. We agree.
>> He rules the everlasting kingdom.
>> Yeah. That's the kingdom of God.
>> Yeah.
>> Yep. So the son of man rules has
dominion in God's kingdom.
>> But like Rajie, don't don't you think
this is an earthly kingdom?
>> It's both. It's not just earthly. It's
both. He brings he he brings his
rulership from heaven to earth and
establishes it on earth as well. He's
ruling in heaven already. He's about to
bring that rulership down to earth as
well.
>> What what what do what do what do the
Jews say about this verse? which Jews
>> like the how did the Jews interpret this
verse?
>> It it it depends, brother. It depends on
which Jews you're asking. Uh but if you
look at some early Targams, you'll see
that uh they say that the Messiah rules
in the kingdom of God. Um you'll get
some other fringe interpretations that I
forget, but I think some will say that
that this is Israel itself. Like you get
some fringe interpretations like that.
That's just silly. But yeah,
>> like I don't know. It it seems it seems
like look look uh look logic like I said
I I'm going to do more research on my
own right about this whole thing. I'm
going to do more research right but yeah
look this was this was a good uh
conversation. It's given me a lot to
think about. I hope I've given you a lot
to think about with that Emmanuel verse
as well like you can look at it uh
critically and understand what I was
trying to tell you. I I think it's a
good point. Well, look. Yeah. I'm I'm
going to uh I'm going I'm on Friday. I'm
going to talk to my shakes and I'm gonna
talk I'm gonna see I'm gonna talk to
>> You're already talking to him.
>> Very funny. Very funny.
>> Come on. You You see the name? Wait,
it's right here. You see the name?
You're already Come on, man. Don't
disrespect me like that, man. Come on,
man.
>> Look, Logic. It's, you know, I' I've
been fasting all day, so
>> Yeah. Like Uh,
>> talk to talk to the shakes. Have have a
good time and
>> bring to me what they say. We'll talk
about it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Hopefully, we can talk
like maybe Friday or something. I'm
going to talk to them and I'm I'm going
to strengthen my arguments and by by the
grace of Allah, you will take the
shahada logic
>> and by the grace of the Lord Jesus
Christ, you will give up the shenanigan
and accept him for who he is and be
saved.
>> Okay. We'll see, man. All right.
>> We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. God
bless, bro. Have a good one. Yeah.
>> All right.
>> I got my guy Sie in the house, man.
What's up, bro?
>> Hi, Logic. How's my favorite Christian
pmicist? How's it going, bro?
>> Pretty good, man. Pretty good, dog.
>> I was I was uh I was in the gym hitting
the weights and I saw on my phone God
loic stream. So, I was like, you know
what? You I got to head up. You know, I
got to head up. So, no man, I've made
great great progress over like the past
like eight months, man. I wish I could
send a pic. Like, I could send you a
pic, but I look great. Let's let's let's
talk about let's talk about, you know,
why we uh we should trust Islam.
>> Wait,
>> wait, before you get into that, did you
>> Yeah,
>> did you look into anything we spoke
about yet? Did you have a chance to look
into some things?
>> Yeah, man. Yeah, I've uh I I I refined a
lot of my beliefs. I talked to shake I
talked to a shake about uh the prophet
in the in the in the jail in the Bible
you know and he did he did also talk
about uh songs of Solomon but uh you
know I looked at that and uh I I don't
think it's uh it's not
>> it's trash huh
>> yeah it's not the prophet you know so
look I'm just going to say it now the
prophet is not mentioned in the Bible
right name he's not mentioned in the
Bible right? It's just what it is. Um I
think that we as Muslims just have to
let that go as well as uh the same
thing. I also looked into the
crucifixion of Jesus, right? And you
know I I think Jesus was crucified,
>> you know, I uh Wait, that's good.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Uh I don't think it
contradicts the Quran though,
>> but I think he was crucified. So I've
I've refined my beliefs. Um, I'm I'm
looking into many things. I I've been
doing a lot of study on the Quran and
the Bible. I still believe in Islam
100%.
But again, I have a better I have a
better understanding of what you
Christians believe in now. And also I
have a lot of critiques too, but I also
have more understanding. So yeah.
>> Okay. So let's I'm I'm more interested
in building off of what we've been
building for the past like I don't know
what was it three streams, man. We've
been talking now. I'm I'm I'm interested
in building off of off of this. So So
you got to the point where you're like,
you know what? Yep. Muhammad is not in
the Bible. Muslims need to let this go.
These arguments that people bring up,
it's weak. It's not good. In context,
they don't work. We need to stop saying
this. We need to stop doing this, right?
It's not it's not really honest. So let
me ask you this, okay? Do you understand
>> the implications of that? Meaning do
like do you understand what that
admission means? When you admit that the
that Muhammad is nowhere in the Bible,
do you know what that means?
>> It doesn't it doesn't mean anything.
Right? Because Jesus could have said
that Ahmed is coming and the disciples
didn't didn't uh write it down. I can
give you an example of this. Right? If
you go to Acts 20:35, Paul says it's
more blessed like Jesus. Paul says as
our Lord says as Jesus says it is more
blessed to give than it is to receive.
Right? And so that must have been a
common saying of Jesus around the time
around his disciples and people who knew
him for Paul who didn't know Jesus to be
saying that right so it must have been
one of the sayings of Jesus but it's not
mentioned in any of the gospels not in
the synoptic gospels not in John. So
there are definitely some things that
Jesus used to say that were are not in
the Bible that that's pardon me that are
not in the gospels. Um I definitely
believe the Bible is corrupted. There's
no doubt in my mind about that. So it
doesn't like uh you know the prophet
Salam
not being in the in the Bible doesn't
mean anything. The Bible contains parts
of the not the full.
>> Okay. So now we've opened up another can
of worms. So one, you're saying that
Jesus could have probably said that
after him.
>> He did say it. He he he said it. It's
not There's no doubt in my mind that he
said it.
>> According to what?
>> According to the Quran.
>> No, no, no. I I know I know the Quran
makes the claim, but what what what is
the proof that he actually said it?
>> The Quran? I mean, you know, I mean, the
Quran says it. It's not mentioned in the
Bible, so there's no other way of
proving it, but the Quran says it,
>> right? So, the Quran just makes a claim
that is it can't it can't get around. It
can't prove. Huh?
>> Well, it's it's
I mean, why why does he why does it why
does it have to why does it have to be
in the Bible? You know, it says Jesus
said it, right? Jesus said my there's
someone coming after me. his um some of
his followers chose to deify him and
they may have just not wanted to uh to
put those parts in because it would have
messed with the whole theory of
deification as we see
>> like I accept like
>> from from Mark
>> just just really quick just really quick
Sully so notice if you have either Jesus
and his words being recorded by the
apostles in the gospel or repeated by
him are repeated in the epistles, right?
Because it was a famous saying or maybe
a tradition that they carried on.
Wouldn't you wouldn't you expect to
either see this in the gospel or see
this in the tradition of the apostles
that Jesus said Ahmed is coming after
him?
>> No. Because it would contradict
>> it would contradict Yeah. It would
contradict the deification of Jesus.
There is not a single
>> How would it contradict? Because if
Jesus says, "Hey, there is someone
coming after me whose name is Ahmed
who's going to set everything straight."
Then Jesus is no longer like the whole
belief in Christianity.
>> He doesn't say he's going to say, He
doesn't say he's going to set everything
straight. The Quran just says a
messenger named Ahmed is going to come
after me. That's all.
>> Yeah, pardon me. He says he's going to
send Akmed after him. It's going to
contradict the whole deification uh of
Jesus because if Jesus is Jesus is God
and he died on the cross, why is he
sending someone else? What what else is
he sending? The only person after Jesus
that he's probably sent that didn't meet
him was Paul. And even Jesus doesn't
prophesy Paul is coming.
>> He Jesus literally says, "I will send
you prophets and scribes." That's in
Matthew chap 20 uh 25:3
or Matthew 23, sorry. Matthew 23:35,
he says, "I'll send you prophets and and
scribes." So, there's nothing wrong with
Jesus.
>> There's nothing wrong with Jesus sending
prophets and scribes after him.
>> Yeah. But the prophet is not just a
prophet or a scribe. He is the prophet.
He's the last one.
>> Yeah. So, this this is not that's that's
your view of Muhammad. I'm asking you're
saying it doesn't make sense. Well, it
wouldn't make sense for for Jesus to
send a prophet that would contradict
him. Right.
>> Wouldn't make sense for Jesus to send a
prophet that would contradict him. Uh,
no.
>> Right. So, the prophet that Jesus sends
or if Jesus was to send somebody named
Ahmed, he would be in 100% agreement
with what Jesus taught. He wouldn't
contradict him in any way. Right.
>> Of course not.
>> Right. So let's say like so if Jesus
said he was going to send somebody named
Ahmed after him that would just simply
mean that Muhammad is not that character
because he contradicts Jesus at every
turn and that Ahmed just had to come
>> that's what that would have meant. Yeah,
exactly. Right. If now I would
understand what you're saying, but
again, you have to look at it from what
my perspective. The Bible is corrupted,
right? The Bible contains part of the
Ineal, but it doesn't have the full
Injeal. There is not a single gospel in
the Bible that is that is from when
Jesus was alive. Right? The Quran is
compiled, not compiled, it's written
down when the prophet was alive. It's
not the same for the Bible. So there's
like a 10 20 year gap.
>> It wasn't compiled in Muhammad's time.
>> Not not compiled. I mean like scribes
had already started writing it down when
the prophet was alive.
>> And then and then they and then they
rewrote it after his death.
>> Pardon?
>> And then they rewrote it after his
death.
>> And they rewrote it after his death.
>> Yes.
>> Who who rewrote it?
>> Abu Bakr had Zade bin Thabad. I'm sorry,
not Abu Bakr. Sorry. Um Man had Z bin
Thabed and three others. uh rewrite the
Quran in what they called perfect
copies.
>> Oh, you mean the uh the
what was uh
>> this is the story of when he had the
other Qurans burned.
>> Yeah. The was the
forgotten it's the consensus of the uh
of the followers, right? So
>> it wasn't a consensus Ib Massud
disagreed with this.
>> Yeah. Look um there was a consensus like
Iban Massud is one person, right? Ib
Massud was one man but
is another as well.
>> Look, uh the
>> and these are two of the people that
Muhammad said you have to learn the
Quran from. They're huge. They're not
just random people.
>> Yeah, I know. Um the the the Quran says
that Allah will protect the Quran from
corruption.
>> Where where does the Quran say that?
>> Hold on.
>> You're thinking of chapter 15:9, huh?
Where it says he he uh sends down the
reminder and he's the guardian of it.
The he's the guards. He guards the
reminder. 15 verse9.
>> Is he? Yeah, we were. Yeah, exactly. The
Quran is pro protected from corruption.
So,
>> it doesn't say the Quran there. It says
the reminder.
>> Yeah.
>> You You know why that's
>> why?
>> Because the Quran calls us the people of
the reminder. Call It calls our book the
reminder.
>> It's certainly we who revealed the
reminder and it is we who
>> Now go now go to chapter 16 verse 43.
Look, uh, wait, wait, wait, wait. Logic.
>> Are we moving away from the topic?
>> I mean, I'm you're you're one of those
guys whose rabbit trails I'm okay with
going with. So, I mean, you moved us
here. I I just follow.
>> No, no. I I I I you know, I I said I
said that I went to You You asked me
like if I went to my shakes. You were
the one who asked me.
>> Yeah. So, we were on the topic of when
you when you acknowledge that Muhammad
is not mentioned in the Bible, we're
talking about why that's a problem.
You're saying that that's not a problem.
>> Yeah. All right. All right. Let's let's
let's
>> It's a problem because the Quran says
he's in the Bible. It says he's in the
Torah and in jail. If he's not there,
then the Quran lied and it's false.
>> But how? It doesn't It says Jesus
mentions that Akmed is coming. It
doesn't say that the disciples of Jesus
wrote down that Ahmed is coming.
>> Oh, it's brother. It also says in
chapter 7 verse 157. It says that they
can find the unlettered prophet written
in the Torah and the Gospel with them.
That's chapter 7 verse 157. Want want to
check that out real quick?
>> Yeah. 7157. They they're the ones who
follow the prophet, the unlettered
prophet, whose description they find in
their Torah and the gospel. He commands
them to do good and forbism from evil,
permits them only what is lawful, and
permits to them what is impure, and he
relieves them from their burdens and
shackles that bound them. Only those who
believe in him, honor, and support him,
and follow the light sent him be
successful. Okay. Um,
>> so he's actually mentioned in the gospel
and in the Torah. Like it's not just a
verbal mention of Jesus. No, he's
actually in the scripture in the text.
>> But it doesn't say the one that's with
them. Unless
>> it literally it literally said, brother,
it literally says with them. Literally.
You want to see?
>> I I'm on I'm on I'm on quran.com right
now.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The the Okay, good. You're
on You're on Quran.com. Quran.com.
>> This is Mustafa Katab.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I butchered it.
If you if you're on quran.com, you can
um press one of the you can press the
Arabic uh words and it'll show you the
translation of the Arabic words. You see
the Arabic words above the verse?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I can see it.
>> Okay. Yeah. So, um one of the words is
the word here is uh is it or? Let me
see. Into. Yeah, it's indom which means
with them in the Arabic.
>> Yeah. Okay. I see I see what you're
talking about.
>> You see it?
>> With them.
>> Yep. So that mean so in the seventh
century what they they had Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John, bro. They had
Acts, they had their letters of Paul,
they had all that. All right.
>> Yeah. Uh the letter prophet whose
description they find in the Torah and
the gospel. Look again again logic.
>> I I I understand what you're talking
about. Again, like I said, look, I'm I'm
going to do I'm going to do even more
research right after this. Right. There
might be there might be
>> there might be uh no there might be like
like you said uh Jesus was talking about
sending uh prophets and uh it might not
be a full
it might not be unambiguous. Look like I
I'm going to I'm going to look into this
more. Right.
>> Okay. Can we agree that if he's not in
the Bible like the Quran says he is
>> cuz it says he's found in the Torah and
the Gospel with them in the seventh
century. That's what we have, right?
This means that if he's not in the
Bible, then the Quran is false and
Muhammad's a false prophet.
>> If the prophet is not in the Bible,
>> but wait, hold on. Let me ask you a
question, right? Why would why would the
why would the Quran right make this
claim, right? I'm just asking you like
logically, right? Why would the Quran
make this claim? Why would the Quran
make this claim if if the prophet isn't
there? It doesn't make sense what you're
saying.
>> Yes, I got you. I'll tell you why. It's
a good good question. The Quran makes
this claim because Muhammad wanted the
Jews and the Christians to believe in
him. That's why you always see the Quran
over and over and over and over again
saying that the Quran came down
confirming that which is with the Jews
and Christians. That's why you see it
over and over again that the Quran is
affirming the scriptures they have and
saying, "Hey, I'm in line with you." So,
matter of fact, watch. Go to chapter
4:47. Here's an example. Go to chapter 4
verse 47.
>> All right. Oh you who Oh you who are
given the book believe in what we have
revealed confirming your own scriptures
before we wipe out your faces turning
them backwards or we condemn the defiant
as we did to the Sabbath breakers and
Allah's command is always executed.
>> So you see how Allah tell commands them
to believe in the Quran. It says,
"Believe in what I have revealed to you,
confirming that which is with you, or
else we're gonna turn your faces upside
down." He
>> I accept that the the Torah and the Ino
have things which with with what God is
has put there. Not everything there is
correct.
Like look, the Bible the Bible was
>> like legally binding for Christians to
follow until the prophet like compiled
the Quran. That's that same thing.
>> Go to chapter 5 verse 47.
>> Come on.
>> You're going to understand you. You know
me by now. You You've seen me enough.
You know me enough. You know I'm not
going to give you any of my opinion. I'm
gonna We're just What's the only thing
we do, Sie?
>> I don't know, man. Z, you know what's
the only thing we do around here, man?
>> Having the slightest clue.
>> We just read, dude. That's all we do. We
just read. That's it. So, I'mma let
I'mma let the Quran answer you, man. So,
you just said that that the Gospel was
legally binding for the Christians
before Muhammad came and compiled the
Quran. Watch this. Go ahead and read
this. Read this verse. Chapter 5:47.
>> So, let let the people of the gospel
judge by what Allah has revealed in it.
And those who do not judge while Allah
is revealed and are truly rebellious.
Yeah.
>> So I agree with that.
>> Good. So the gospel even while the Quran
is revealed is still legally binding on
the on the Christians, right?
>> No. But logic that doesn't make sense.
If if if the Christianity was still
legally binding, then there's no point
in following Islam. It doesn't make
sense.
>> NO, IT DOESN'T make sense. No, it
doesn't make sense.
>> No, no, no. Listen, listen. doesn't make
sense.
>> Listen, listen. According to the Quran,
there's like you got to open your mind
to the Quran's view. The Quran's view is
that Christianity and Judaism, they are
not different religions than Islam. The
Torah, following the Torah and following
the Gospel is Islam according to the
Quran. You understand? But the Quran
also, the Quran also says in 9:30, do
not say that Jesus is the is the
Messiah. So it already knows what the
Christians believe about Jesus.
>> That he's Lord, that he's that he's
Lord. It says he's the Messiah.
>> Nabi Isa is our right.
>> Yeah. Yeah. He's he's the Messiah, but
they it says that they make him Lord
besides Allah, and they should be. So
why would why what you're saying is that
the Quran is saying that the Bible is is
binding, right?
>> Even though it it commits sh it doesn't
make sense.
>> Let me tell you because Muhammad who is
the author of this Quran or whoever this
author of the Quran is
>> well that's that's your that's you're a
Muslim. You're going to say that. Try to
look try to step outside of that for a
second and look at it from an objective
view. the Quran and whoever the author
of the Quran is does not know what is in
the scriptures that it says it's
confirming. That's why it's making these
mistakes of saying that the gospel is
true and that Christians should judge by
it while at the same time contradicting
what is in the gospel. Not knowing it.
It's not knowing that it's contradicting
the gospel. That's why it keeps making
this mistake. It doesn't know that it's
it look you you'll see a lot of times
where the the Quran says that the people
distort the book with their tongues that
they lie about what Allah has said that
they misinterpret what Allah has said
right it so it it accuses the confusion
and the falsehoods on what people say
not on the scriptures themselves.
>> So the Quran is unaware that the
scriptures are actually teaching these
things. It's not that the people are
misunderstanding them. This is what the
scriptures are teaching. Okay? So that's
and this is what is called the Islamic
dilemma. The Quran is affirming the
gospel while while contradicting the
gospel saying that Jesus is not the son
of Allah that he's not Lord. But the
gospel says that he's the son of God and
he's lord. That's why the Quran
>> All right. All right. Look, logic. All
right.
>> Do you understand the point?
>> Yeah. I I already know like I I know
about the the Islamic dilemma you know I
have been watching you for like uh like
a month so I understand like I don't
understand it fully but I understand it
in principle right um so it's I I
understand what you guys are trying to
say but yeah I know you guys don't like
the prophet right you guys don't agree
with him you don't think he's a real
prophet and all these things but at the
very least you have to accept some level
of human intelligence
that you can at least agree that the
prophet has a certain level of
intelligence that he's not going to make
certain mistakes for someone to
establish a religion this big. He can't
be an idiot, right?
>> Yes. No. Yes. What are you talking
about? Look, Jesus says this, brother,
listen listen. It's it's brilliant. It's
actually genius. Notice what a lot of
false prophets like, for example, have
you you have you heard of Mormonism?
>> Yeah, I've heard of Mormonism. It's like
the the white version of like Hebrew
West, right? No, it's the white version
of Islam.
>> It's the white version of Islam, big
dog. Look, they have Yes. They have this
this this white dude named Joseph Smith
who claims to have gotten a private
revelation from God just like Muhammad
claims to have been just like Muhammad,
a white man who who claimed to have
gotten a private revelation from God in
a cave. Joseph Smith got a private
revelation, right? receive. He the only
one who was able to receive these
tablets and read these tablets, this
gold golden tablets, whatever, came up
with the Book of Mormon. And guess what?
He claims that his message is a
continuation
of Jesus's message and Moses and the
rest. Sound familiar?
>> Okay. All right. If you're going to use
this logic, why not use it against Paul?
Right? Paul comes after and he corrupts
the message of Jesus.
>> You know what? Why don't use this
against Paul?
>> You know what? That that's a good point,
brother. I I don't want to be a
hypocrite. You're right, Si. I don't
want to be a hypocrite. If I'm going to
call out Muhammad and I'm going to call
out Joseph Smith, I better call out
Paul, too, right? So, let me do this,
okay? Cuz I got to have equal scales cuz
you're right. When I when I say wait,
>> wait a second, Sie.
>> If we're going to to examine Paul and we
say that he corrupted the message of
Jesus, this means that we know the
message of Jesus which Paul corrupted.
Right? So what is the message of Jesus
that Paul corrupted? Where do we find
the message of Jesus?
So Jesus there's some things in like I
said some things in the New Testament
are correct but Paul really does a lot
of in the acts of the apostles right
>> I'm lost hold on that for forget all
that what is the message of Jesus that
Paul where where do we find it where do
we find message of Jesus
>> we look at the we look at the Quran and
we look at the Jew and look at the Quran
>> we look really
>> we look at both of them and we look one
matches up.
>> Ah, I see. I see. I see. So, the message
of Jesus is in is in the gospel. I mean
in the Quran. Okay. What what did Jesus
teach? What did Jesus teach about the
law? Did he come to change the law?
>> Did he come to change the law?
>> Yeah.
>> Well, according to the Bible, look,
according to the Bible, he never
abolishes the law. But Paul does. That's
>> Is Paul wrong for that? I disagree, but
let me go with you. Is Paul Is Paul
wrong for that? if he abolished the law
or taught that Jesus abolished the law.
>> Yeah, he's absolutely wrong for that.
That's bid and that's a false prophecy.
The same thing you said for John Smith
or what his name and claim about the
prophet.
That's what is doing.
>> I'm with you. So if somebody came and
taught that Jesus changed the law or
they themselves changed the law, that's
a false prophet, right?
>> That's a false prophet. Man, you
Christians follow a false prophet. Go go
go go to chapter 3:50 in your in your
Quran.
>> We reject bulis, man. We reject buliffs.
>> Okay. Muham Muhammad didn't.
>> How do you how do you know?
>> Uh, according to your sources, man, you
ever read Muhammad's story? We'll put
that aside for a second. Go to chapter
3:50.
>> And I will confirm, and this is
>> Uhhuh.
>> And I will confirm the Torah revealed
before me and legalize some of what had
been forbidden to you. I have come to
you with a sign from your Lord. So be
mindful of Allah and obey me. So
>> Jesus came Jesus came according to this
verse, he came to legalize some things
that were forbidden in the Torah.
>> Yeah.
>> So then according to the Quran, Issa is
a false pro or really Muhammad is a
false prophet for teaching Jesus came to
change the law. Right.
>> Muhammad's a false prophet.
>> Come logic. Come on. Listen. This is no
>> logic. Right. This is completely
different from what from what Paul did.
I can explain I can explain the
difference because Paul
let me speak Paul
>> he he banned he banned circumcision like
he said circumcision is no longer
necessary
>> no hold on hold
>> he said it's not necessary anymore
>> hold on a second let's just go slowly
remember what we agreed to we agreed
that if somebody is teaching that Jesus
changed the law or they themselves
changed the law, then that person is a
false prophet, a false messenger that
committing bidda and innovation.
>> But Jesus But Paul didn't say Jesus
changed the law.
>> That exactly you're right.
>> He said he believed.
>> Just one second. You agree that if
someone taught that Jesus changed the
law, they are a false prophet, right?
>> I don't agree.
>> But you agreed to that earlier.
>> I think I did. And I was mad for doing
that. Yeah, I was misguided to do that.
>> You No, you're saying that you're
misguided for doing that because you you
got Muhammad in trouble. Muhammad taught
that Jesus changed the law. Now all of a
sudden when you are consistent in your
logic and thinking now all of a sudden
and it works against Muhammad all of a
sudden now you are misguided. No, you
are not misguided. You are right. You
are absolutely correct Si. If someone is
teaching that Jesus came to change the
law and or they themselves changed the
law, right? Then guess what? That person
is a false prophet and a false teacher.
You are absolutely correct on that.
That's what Jesus says. I did not come
to abolish the law, but to fulfill it.
He didn't come to remove it, change it.
He came to fulfill it, to complete it.
Muhammad taught that Jesus came to
change it, which is opposite of what he
said. Muhammad's a false prophet
according to our standard. He he he came
to allow some of the things which were
forbidden before like uh I think camel
meats and the like right like these are
minor things
>> who cares
>> like minor things
>> brother who cares if it's big to you or
whatever minor or major it doesn't
matter Jesus said not one tit in that
same passage I did not come to abolish
the law but to fulfill it not one dot
not one tit of the law will pass away
until it's fulfilled.
>> So, so why so why why is circumcision no
longer
>> asking me Christian theology is is
secondary I can break all this down to
you later I first I want to I want you
to be consistent and see how by your own
standard Muhammad is a false prophet
don't change up on me now man
>> look from what I said before by that
standard I was misguided Allah forgive
me
>> why why were you misguided
>> I made a mistake look I I was I was I
was under I'm a human being. I'm a human
being, man. I've been human. How is How
is that a mistake? How How is that a
mistake?
>> Look, logic, right? I've I've been I've
been a Muslim for for four years, right?
So, right, my my parents uh I grew up in
a quote quote unquote Muslim home, but
we weren't very religious. So, my
knowledge of the Quran isn't as good as
it should be. It's just like in the past
few weeks that I've really been
studying. Oh, I don't know as much as
the Quran as even you do. So, I'm going
to make certain mistakes. Like, if I had
known, I I wouldn't have said it.
>> I hear you. That's not answering the
question. How was that a mistake? When
you when you say that if somebody
teaches that Jesus came to change the
law, then that person is a false prophet
according to what Jesus said about
himself that he didn't.
>> I I Yeah, I forgot I forgot about Quran
350. So, it's a mistake.
>> But, no, no, no. That's not your
mistake. That's not your mistake. You're
being honest and consistent. And when
you are, notice when you are honest and
consistent, the conclusion comes to
inevitably that Muhammad is a false
prophet. That's the conclusion. When
you're honest and consistent, but then
you got to you got to downplay yourself
and say you were misguided or you made a
mistake. I'm not going to let you do
that. I love you too much. You were
right on the money. You were consistent.
You were honest. You were logical. And
that all of that can led you to Muhammad
being a false prophet. So you don't take
your brain out of the sight just because
it proves Muhammad's a false prophet.
Keep your brain and throw away Muhammad
and cling to Jesus. Dude, stop playing
these games now, man. The time is up.
>> I I I love Jesus. I love Jesus, right?
I've already told you many times. I love
Nabi Issa. He's one of the greatest
prophets. We We love him. So I don't
know why you keep saying come see Jesus.
I'm already with him.
>> You don't know him yet.
>> I'm with him.
>> But you you soon. Lord willing, man. You
You will soon.
>> I know him. You You You know Allah. God
willing. Logic. You already call
yourself shake. So you will know him,
right? So it's a it's it's look logic.
Look, I made look I made a mistake,
right? Like I said, you you as a
Christian know the Quran better than me.
I'm I'm still learning. Like I'm not a
kafise. So I made a mistake. If I had
known that, I I forgot about 350. If I
said that, I wouldn't have and I also uh
didn't really uh summarize what Paul
said. Well,
>> Paul didn't really he didn't really
claim that uh that Jesus
abolished the law, but he did a lot of
Buddha is what I'm trying to say, right?
That's what I meant to say.
>> All right. So, when you say, let's let's
keep going with this. When you say
bidda, meaning innovation,
>> right? meaning going away from what is
what is taught making up his own thing.
Right?
>> Yeah. When you say someone is committing
bida innovation that means that you have
an original standard that you that is
your foundation to where if someone is
innovating you can point the innovation
out
>> right that's how you know someone is
innovating is because you have a
standard already set right
>> okay
>> so when you say Paul is innovating away
from the message of Jesus what is the
message of Jesus
>> where can we get the message of Jesus as
our standard so that we can see if Paul
is actually innovating or not or
Muhammad is innovating or not. Where's
the message of Jesus?
>> Paul Paul is not just um innovating
against the message of Jesus. He's
innovating against the whole Old
Testament, right? He's so
>> I got you. If if someone is disagreeing
with the whole Old Testament, is that
person a false prophet?
>> If I'm going to be careful the way I
answer this, right? It doesn't answer
obvious. What do you mean careful? It's
obvious. No, it doesn't necessarily mean
that they are a false prophet because
the Old Testament is uh is corrupted,
right? It's
>> okay. So, if the Old Testament is
corrupted, then Paul going against the
Old Testament is not a problem then. So,
so bring
not every part not every part of the Old
Testament is corrupted.
>> Got it. So, the parts that are not
corrupted of the Old Testament, let me
ask you this. Yeah.
>> If you go against the authentic parts of
the Old Testament, then you're a false
prophet. Is that right?
>> You go against Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. What's a What's an authentic
part of the Old Testament?
>> I mean, I can I I can't list I can tell
you the ones which are false.
>> I don't care about the I care about the
true ones. I don't care about the
irrelevant. I need an authentic. What
parts of the Old Testament are authentic
so that we can judge Paul, Muhammad, and
Joseph Smith?
>> Joseph Smith. the Mormon guy.
>> The Mormon guy.
>> Why? Like I'm I'm I'm not I'm I'm not a
Mormon. You like
>> I know you're not a Mormon, but this is
but but this is how I have a Mormon
audience, too. But this is this is how
we judge a true prophet from a false
one. Look, Muhammad is in the same boat
as Joseph Smith. He ain't no different.
Okay? He's no different. We got to we
got to judge them by the same standard.
All of them.
>> Bro, Mormons Mormons are heretics for
Christians. Islam is the second largest
religion in the world. Muslims are a
tiny sect. No, we're not. They're huge,
bro. What are you talking about?
Mormons. Mormon is a
>> They're a tiny sect. They're like
>> they're their own.
>> Okay. Yeah. So, you just tared them. You
said they're not Christians. Exactly.
>> Correct. They're not Christians. They're
their own religion just like Islam is.
According to the Christians, they're
both pag both of you guys are pagans.
>> But they don't they think that Jesus is
is God?
>> They believe he's a god, a separate god
from the father. They're polytheists.
>> Whoa.
>> Yeah. But let's get back to it. Okay. So
everybody's on equal scales. Everybody's
on equal scales. All right.
>> All right. All right.
>> When we What is an authentic? What is
the authentic Old Testament? So we can
make sure Joseph Smith, uh, Muhammad,
Paul are all in good standing or if
they're in bad standing.
>> All right. I'm going to point you to a
verse in the Old Testament that Paul
contradicts. Isaiah 52:1. The
uncircumcised will not enter the temp of
Jerusalem again.
>> Is Is that authentic?
>> Isaiah is I wouldn't say Isaiah is fully
authentic, but
>> So then So then that's out. Can you give
me something authentic?
>> Fully authentic.
Well, let me let me get a list of the
books. Hold on. List of the Old
Testament.
>> You just say you don't know what is
authentic and what isn't. Just say that.
>> I I know I know what is not authentic,
but I I don't know.
>> For you to know what is not authentic.
Wait, stop. For you to know what is not
authentic means you know what is
authentic, right?
>> Yeah. We use the Quran to judge what is
authentic.
>> You you use the Quran. And there we are
again. We're back to using the Quran to
judge what is authentic. Yet your Quran
never says this. This is circular
reasoning that puts you in a bind. And
it's something it's a logic that doesn't
exist in your religion. Your Quran says
to come to us. Your Quran says Muhammad
is found in our scriptures. Your Quran
says that it confirms our scriptures.
So, you're doing it backwards, dude.
Your Quran says your scriptures are
authentic.
>> The reason the reason I can't confirm
Isaiah is he's not mentioned in the
Quran, right? But look, I would say
let's look at let's look at a man who we
can all agree on, Ezek Moses, right?
Even though uh part of the look, no
matter how we do it, like no matter,
there's still going to be some
corruption as long as it doesn't align
with the Quran. That's why
There it is right there. As long as it
doesn't align with the Quran, you will
deem it as a corruption regardless of
the objective fact of the the
reliability of the text. If it disagrees
with what you believe, you're going to
just deny it as a corruption. That is
dishonest thinking. Can like for
example, can I do the same thing? If I
say if if I say the parts of the Quran
that disagree with the Bible, those
parts of the Quran are corrupted. Can I
say that?
>> You can't because your Bible doesn't
mention the Your Bible doesn't mention
us. You guys don't believe.
>> It doesn't have to. It doesn't have to.
The Bible says that it's true. The Bible
says that Christ's words never pass
away. Heaven and earth will pass away,
but his words will never pass away. It
claims to be the word of God. It claims
to be God breathed. All scripture is God
breathed and inspired by the Holy
Spirit. So the scripture clearly claims
to be divine inspiration from God. So if
something contradicts inspiration from
God, then that's falsehood. So now if I
go see look at your Quran and I say, "Oh
yeah, you know what? Parts of the Quran
that disagree with the Bible, that
part's corrupted." Can I say that? Is
that fair for me to say as a Christian?
Is that good a good methodology to have?
>> I mean, you could you could say it,
right? You could say that you could make
that claim.
>> Is that a good methodology for me to
have if I'm talking about truth and
object and objectivity?
>> It's not it's not a good like it's not a
good methodology. But at the end of the
day, we believe
>> why are you using it?
>> We believe in Allah on on faith. You
understand what I'm saying? You believe
in Allah.
>> Blind blind faith.
>> See,
>> blind faith.
>> Let me tell you what the Bible says
about faith. The Bible says that faith
isn't blind. It says that faith is the
substance of things hoped for, the
evidence of things not seen. Faith, true
faith according to the Bible, is based
in evidence. So even though you haven't
seen something, you have the evidence to
trust it. You have a reason to trust.
You have a basis to trust it. With
Islam, you're talking about blind faith.
You don't have a basis. You don't have a
reason. There's no evidence of it.
You're just going to believe it blindly
and claim it. Believe any claim.
>> Logic. All religion is based on faith.
Like Christians, like no Christian has
ever seen Jesus face to face, but they
believe in him. Like
>> you just missed what I said, brother.
You just missed what I said. I'm not
saying that religion isn't based on
faith. At least Christianity.
Christianity is based on faith. The
Bible tells us what faith is. And it
says, I'll repeat it again. This is
Hebrews chapter.
>> Can you give me the Could you give me
the verse?
>> Yeah. Hebrews chapter 11:3. Hebrews 11.
>> Hebrews 11:3. All right. Uh
>> I'm sorry. That's not the one.
>> If you understand that verse, it's verse
one. Sorry, verse one.
>> All right. One. Now, faith is the
substance of things hoped for, the
evidence of things not seen.
>> See, you see how according to the Bible,
faith is based in evidence.
>> Yeah.
>> So, true faith is not blind. It's not
just I'mma just believe it just cuz.
>> True faith gives you reason to put your
trust in something. That's what true
faith is. Gives you evidence. Here's the
evidence. So now, even though you
haven't seen what the evidence points
to, you still have the evidence and
therefore you can now trust it. You can
put your you can choose to trust the
evidence. That's what faith is. It's a
trust. You're putting your trust into
something that has a basis. Even though
I haven't seen Jesus, I have the
evidence of his resurrection, the
evidence of his crucifixion, the the
prophetic evidence of of of his of his
crucifixion and his coming and his birth
and when all this stuff happened. I have
the evidence even though I haven't seen
Jesus with my own eyes. I have the
evidence. So I I have the hope. I can
put my hope and my trust in Christ who I
have not seen because he's given me
evidence to believe him, you know. So
>> yeah. Yeah. uh logic. I I I understand
what you're saying, right? You're
basically you're trying to make the
claim that there's more evidence for
your views than mine, right? That's what
you're trying to say.
>> Both both from the Quran and the Bible,
brother.
>> Yeah. There there are some things that I
I like I said, I accept that Jesus was
crucified. Like I've looked into the
evidence, right? Jesus was crucified on
the cross. Like I accept that. Yeah.
there are some things that I've had to
adapt to my worldview because like you
know I don't want to look like an idiot
you know the whole uh substitution
theory it's it's al it's also
theologically problematic like saying
that God put someone else on the cross
in place of Jesus but yeah I agree
there's there's there's good evidence
for many taking Christianity not
everything it's still it's it's still a
there's also good evidence for Islam No,
>> no, because there is none.
>> Do you don't understand the evidence
that the Quran uses, bro? Listen to what
I'm saying.
>> Yeah.
>> The evidence that the Quran uses for why
it's true is based on the Bible. Do you
understand what I'm saying?
>> It's saying we should believe in the
Quran. Like remember the verse I showed
you 4:47. We should believe in the Quran
because it confirms what we have. So if
we don't believe in the Quran, we're
basically going against our own
scripture because it's in line with the
Quran. The Quran's in line with our
scriptures. We can find Muhammad
mentioned in our scriptures. We can even
find the Quran itself mentioned in our
scriptures according to chapter 26. So
the Quran is using the Bible as its
evidence for it being true. It says, "If
you are in doubt about what Allah has
revealed to you, go and ask those who've
been reading the scripture before you."
The evidence that the Quran is true and
that you shouldn't doubt it is that it's
in line with what came before it. That's
the evidence. Unfortunately for the
Quran, when we look at the evidence and
we take the Quran for what it says, the
evidence works against the Quran because
it's actually not in line with the
previous scriptures like it claims to
be. Muhammad's not in the previous
scriptures like the Quran claims he is.
The Quran is not mentioned in the
previous scriptures like the Quran
claims it is. And when you come to us,
if you're doubting what the Quran says,
you come to us, we're going to
demonstrate to you from the scriptures
that what the Quran is saying is false
and therefore you should doubt it. The
evidence that the Quran gives for itself
logic.
>> Go ahead.
>> Logic. That's That's why I asked, "Are
you trying Are you trying to claim that
the prophet didn't know what the Torah
and the Bible said?" That's why you
That's why you're claiming that.
>> Exactly. Yes. He did not know what was
in those scriptures. He didn't know.
>> But if you you you're the one claiming
that the prophet is a false is a false
prophet, right? So, if I'm Let's assume
I'm a false prophet, why would I why
would I go and and make such a crazy
claim that can be debunked? It doesn't
make sense
>> because
>> wouldn't it have been easier for the
prophet to just say, "Hey, I'm coming
with this book. Forget about the Jews
and the Christians. God doesn't care
about them." Like why why why go through
all this trouble to go to the Jews and
Christians and confirm like what what
point does it serve? Because un
unfortunately the reality is bro is that
people although people will dis will
call him out for the false prophet he is
there are other who are gullible and
unnowledgeable who will be duped and and
deceived. Let me let me let me show you
man. This is why I said man you you got
to get into the Bible bro. Jesus tells
us this before it happens man. Jesus in
the gospel he tells us this before it
happens. I'll put it on the screen for
us. But look at what Jesus warns us
about. Look at what Jesus warns us
about. One second. Look at this, man.
Matthew chap 24.
Verse 24 and 25. Matthew
>> verse 24.
>> Yeah. For false Christ and Come on, man.
>> Go ahead. Just go ahead and read it.
You'll see the point I'm making. Go
ahead.
>> Come on. For for false Christs and false
prophets will arise and perform great
signs and wonders so as to lead astray,
if possible, even the elect. See, I have
told you beforehand.
>> See, I told you before it happened. Many
false prophets will come out and they
will deceive a lot of people. They're
going to be successful and they're going
to lead people astray. People are going
to get got. There's going to be people
claiming to be Christ and some people
are going to get got. There's people,
bro, there's people I don't know if
you've seen um he actually recently got
arrested. I forgot his name, but he was
claiming to be Jesus for years and had
and people moved from their homes, sold
their houses to go live um in this area
where there this this site where they
bought it like a field or whatever and
to and gave it to them, sold it to go
live with him and gave it to him, gave
the money and the funds to him. He was
claiming to be Jesus for years. People
get got. There are there are people.
Look, he that's an outrageous claim.
It's so obvious he's not Jesus, right?
Why would he make such a stupid claim
that could be easily debunked and called
out? Because there are there's others
that are gullible and that are easy to
be led astray. And that's what happens.
False prophets come, they lead many
astray. Many. That's what Muhammad did,
not just him. That's what that guy
claiming to be Jesus did. That's what
Joseph Smith did. Led many people
astray. Okay. So, it's not it's not so
out out of out, you know, out
otherworldly to think like, man, why
would he say something so obviously
false in the midst of people who can
call him out, which they were. They were
calling him out, saying that he was
telling fables that they already heard
before, telling tales of old.
>> Where where did they where did they call
him out?
>> Yeah. In the Quran, in the Quran, they
it says that they were saying that he
was telling tales of old stuff that we
heard already.
>> Let me get let me get you these verses.
They was calling them out. The Quran is
is is documenting it. Let's see if I can
uh remember remember the verse. Let me
let me get the eye out for you. Let me
get that eye out. Uh
these are Thanks, DJ. We got chapter 8
verse 31. Man, my my team is quick with
it. All right. Chapter 8:31 it says I'll
put on the screen it says and when our
verses are recited to them they say we
have heard this if we wish we can say
the like of this is nothing but the
tales of the ancients they're calling
them out we heard this already we heard
this stuff before we we tell these
stories ourselves you ain't giving us
nothing new but he's he's giving these
tales and these fables as if they're
revelation of from Allah Ah, these are
popular stories everybody knows about.
>> Like like what stories? Like the story
of Moses
>> like the story of Moses, the story of
the of the of the sleepers,
um,
all of these different all of these
stories, bro. All
>> like the the Quran the Quran doesn't say
that it's an entirely like new
revelation. We know that a lot of the
the Nabi the prophets of before their
stories are retold. They just could like
like for example, we look at even the
story of like Lot is in the Bible. He's
not a prophet, but he's in the Bible,
too. So just it being just it being uh
uh being known to the people doesn't
mean doesn't mean it's false. Like we we
have false prophets in Islam. After
Muhammad died, after the prophet died,
there were guys like Mama who came up
who were saying absolute rubbish. We
know that they're they're false
prophets, right? I mean, because we're
aware of these things.
>> Wait, how do you how do you know that
they're false prophets?
>> Was a false prophet. He was a liar.
>> How do you know
>> was a liar? You said he's a prophet. And
there's no no other prophet after after
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam.
>> How do you know?
>> Because the the Quran because because
Yeah. Because the the you know the Quran
says it, you know.
>> The Quran says so. That's fine. The
Quran says so. So you're basing you're
using the Quran as a standard to judge
if someone is a false prophet if they
disagree with the Quran, if they're
coming against the Quran after, right?
Claiming to be claiming to be in line
with Muhammad but then contradicting
Muhammad when he says that he's also a
prophet, right?
>> Ma the prophet he he he rebuked Mama in
his own lifetime, right? He said mama
sent him a letter saying we let's split
Arabia between ourselves. And the
prophet said, "Get away from me. You're
a liar. You're a false prophet. I have
nothing to do with you."
>> Was Was he was he claiming to be in line
with Muhammad, though?
>> I mean, if you can call if you can call
it that like his Quran was rubbish.
>> Yeah. But was he claiming to be in line
with Muhammad?
>> Yeah.
>> And how did you know that he wasn't in
line with Muhammad?
>> I mean, we we we have we have uh we have
fragments of of of his Quran. He has
stupid stuff like, "Oh, a frog is a frog
because it jumps." Just moronic stuff
like that.
>> Well, let's let's not talk because
brother, we can go to the hadith and see
monkeys getting stoned for adultery and
a bunch of crazy stupid stuff in the
Hadith, bro. That So, let's if you're if
that's your criteria, you got to throw
away Muhammad, bro. Like, I mean, come
on, man. If that's your criteria, but I
don't I don't want to get into all that.
I'm just saying my point is is that you
um you're able to judge this person as a
false prophet because he claimed to be
in line with Muhammad and said things
that go against Muhammad and and said
other dumb things. Is that correct?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I can I can see
I I can see what you're saying, man. Uh
I can see what you're saying.
>> You're you you are you are us. We are
you when it comes to that guy
>> with Muhammad, bro. He claims to be in
line with Jesus, says stupid things in
Hadith. He aim in the Quran and
disagrees with what Jesus says and
disagrees with Moses and the rest. For
us, just like how for you, that guy, I
forget how you pronounce his name, but
that dude,
>> okay, thank you. He's an obvious false
prophet. It's the same for us. Muhammad
is an obvious false prophet, bro. for
the same reasons you judge that guy to
be a false prophet.
>> Amen.
>> Hey DJ.
>> Hey, God bless, brother.
>> Hey, Sully. My friend DJ had some um had
some insight on like more more of those
claims where they uh where they're
calling Muhammad out for fables and
stuff. He uh he has some a little bit
more insight on that than I do. You
wanted to share some?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Let's hear it,
man.
>> Okay. Yeah, I got you. Um,
so there's I mean Avery read a verse
8:31 saying we heard stuff like this
before and you also have you know him
saying that uh they're calling him the
ear. You have it in um in his biography
and you also have it in the Quran
chapter 9:61 saying he is the ear
because he just listens to things and he
hears stories. But I wanted to give you
a simple example. No, doesn't doesn't I
think they call him the ear like the
detractors they call him an ear as an
insult for being gullible or something.
>> Yeah. Because he listens to things and
he thinks they're true
>> and repeats them as if they're true.
>> Yeah. But let let me share let me share
one thing with you. All right. You know
chapter 3 49 where Christ he um makes
clay birds, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. And he he with the
permission of Allah he he it's not him
alone. He asked Allah for permission,
>> right? So that actually comes from the
infancy Gospel of Thomas
>> and that was like a hundred years before
the Quran came out.
>> And so
>> the Gnostics, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's a Gnostic story. So I
can actually share this. Let me see if I
could share this. All right.
>> Okay.
>> I'll put it in the private chat.
>> You you can uh Are you on your phone?
>> I'm on my computer.
>> Yeah, you can you can share your screen.
>> Here we go.
>> Having me do all the work.
>> Okay. Let's see. press uh I don't know
if you know how to do it.
>> My computer My computer is slow and old,
so I'm just
>> Oh, don't worry. I got it. I got us.
Don't worry about it, man.
>> I'm here to do this.
>> I can try Let me Let me try this.
>> Hold on.
>> Yeah. Uh I I can see it, right? Um
>> is it showing on screen?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. How How would the How would the
prophet have known about the Gospel of
Thomas? Like wasn't the Nag Hamadi
library just like rediscovered like some
decades ago?
>> Because these stories they were this is
an oral tradition. Yeah. If you look at
chapter 2, I just want to show you and
read it out. This is from chapter 2 of
the uh link that I that I gave. The
child Jesus was 5 years old after it
rained and he was playing at the ford of
a flowing stream and stirred up dirty
waters. He gathered them into pools. He
made them clean and excellent, ordering
them by by word alone and not ordering
them by deed. Then having take soft clay
from the mud. He formed 12 sparrows from
it. But it was Sabbath when he did these
things and many children um were with
him. And also we can there's so many
more um I'll share I got to stop sharing
screen and chap so you know in chapter
19 verse uh of the Quran verse 28-30 how
he talks in the cradle.
>> Yeah. Jesus uh he says, "Peace be upon
me the day that I'm born, the day that
uh the day I die." I can't remember the
exact wording, but something like that.
Right.
>> Right. So, this actually comes from the
Arabic infancy gospel of the savior.
Look at this. In the name of the In the
name of the father, the son, and the
holy spirit. So, he's taken from a
trinitarian
passage. One god
>> with help of the favor of the most high.
Um let's see. Oh, yep. Section one, we
find what follows in the book of Joseph,
the high priest who lived in the time of
Christ. Some say that he is Caiaphas. He
said that Jesus spoke and indeed when he
was lying in his cradle said to Mary,
his mother, I am Jesus, the son of God.
So, I mean, he had to even take this
this uh version and kind of twist it to
his own. He's speaking in the cradle
saying, "I am Jesus, the son of God, the
logos." Yikes. I mean, that make him
that makes him God. Um, the father sent
me for the salvation of the world.
>> But, uh, we we we also take Esau as as
the logos, as the word of God.
>> I know. And that's the problem for you
guys because that's what that that's
what makes him God.
>> Do do you see how um do you see how
Muhammad he's called the ear? People are
saying, "We heard things like these
before. If we want to, we could repeat
it ourselves." And you could see it just
in a basic example. And then I have many
more examples. You know the se you know
the seven sleepers story.
>> Could you repeat it again? The seven
sleepers.
>> Sure. I got you. The seven sleepers is
in chapter 17 I believe. Chapter 18. And
it's specifically verse 9 uh verses 9-
26.
>> Yeah.
>> You said 9- 26. That was a little Okay.
>> Yeah. We don't have to read it all. But
this is this is a this is a like
Christian story. you know, some some
traditions try to say, you know, it's
true. Um, but other others say, you
know, it's just, you know, a story to
tell to help encourage people. The thing
is is that it glorifies Christ that he
died for us and he was the son of God
and uh they believe in the trinity. So,
I can actually share this uh share this
screen instead if you want.
>> Yeah.
>> Yep. It's up.
>> Okay, cool. The seven sleepers. And you
see this? It talks about Christ Jesus
and how he's he's the son of God and
he's gonna here I could do control
Father Son. Okay. Well, it's been a
while since I've gone through this, but
it talks about how Jesus is the son of
God who came to die for our sins.
>> I think I heard you say that you believe
in the crucifixion,
>> but he is the son of God and they
believe they they baptize in the name of
the Trinity. And yeah, this is a
Christian this is a Christian tale that
they that they say and this is what
Muhammad heard.
>> But do what do what do you guys think of
these uh these books? Like I know you
guys don't accept Gnostics, right?
>> Correct. Exactly.
>> Does does the So all of these are all
these tales only from Christians? Is he
does he only there's Jewish fables too?
I mean if you want to see an example
look this is funny. Um Muhammad, you
know the story, you know, um about
Muhammad um teaching the punishment of
the grave.
>> Yeah.
>> That was taken from Jewish women.
>> From a Jewish woman.
>> Yeah. Listen to Jewish women here. Let
me uh let me get this out for you.
>> We're still waiting. We're still
waiting.
>> Hold on.
>> Before
Christ's return,
>> I'll share the
>> We're still waiting.
>> That's a copy of the private chat. You
looking for some? Oh, in the private
chat.
>> We're still waiting. Come in.
>> Okay. I guess it's up to me, guys. I
guess it's up to me,
>> man. I don't do this as much as you.
>> I know you don't.
>> Destroyer.
>> Good that you recognize your rookiness.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, you didn't even give me the link to
the actual hadith. You
>> what?
>> Rookie
Maja 347. I got it, man. Good lord.
>> Come on, DJ. You slowing us down, man.
>> Down, DJ. H go ahead and give him a go
give him moose mind again. Go ahead give
him give him moose again.
>> We're still waiting.
>> All right. All right. Look, let me let
me ask you guys a question, right? And
DJ DJ wrote, you could you could answer
this as well because we're talking about
evidence. Is there anything in the Quran
that is historically untrue that without
a shadow of a doubt it is proven to be
wrong? Like if you if you could show me
that then that would be that could be uh
an issue for me. If you could show me
that there's something in the Quran that
is taken historically as fact but is
rejected then yeah I could I could see
where you're coming from, right?
>> Yeah. I mean I would say well you you
accept the crucifixion um and I guess
you
>> I I guess you can try and get around
that but one thing that it does do is it
denies Jesus being the son of God. And
that is historically that's and you know
biblically that is just uh not true.
>> Clearly
>> it says the Samaritan was the one who
built the calf the golden calf after the
Exodus. Samaritans weren't weren't there
yet. That's one. But uh I got this
hadith up. Is this the one?
>> Plenty blunders man. It was that Abbas
said the messenger of Allah passed by
two new graves. Is this the one uh DJ?
>> Yeah. Oh let me go to Sahib Bakari
actually
>> here. This is the one I was looking for.
>> Sai Bukari.
>> Sahibari 6366.
And here, let me actually just share my
>> Oh, that's a little close.
>> Is he asking to be proven wrong via the
previous scriptures?
>> No, just his history period. Like
>> just in general.
>> Yeah, I'm sharing my screen.
>> Oh, you're sharing your screen. Okay.
General confirmation of history.
>> General confirmation of history. Can you
uh zoom in a zoom in on that?
>> Let's see.
just yes more a little bit more. So the
other hadith the other hadith could help
because it's it's showing that uh you
know they're teaching there's punishment
of the grave. But look look this is
where he got it from. Sah albakari 6366.
Two old ladies from the Jewish two um
ladies among the Jewish ladies entered
upon me and said the dead are punished
in their graves. But I thought they were
telling a lie and I did not believe them
in the beginning. When they went away
and the prophet entered upon me I said
oh Allah's messenger to old ladies and
told him the whole story. He said they
told the truth. Huh, that's coincidence.
The dead are really punished to the
extent that all the animals hear the
sound resulting from their punishment.
Since then, I always saw him seeking
refuge with Allah from the punishment of
the grave and his prayers.
>> So, he got the punishment of the grave
from these Jews and then just repeated
that like it was a revelation from
Allah.
>> Is this is this in the uh the Talmud or
the Jewish scriptures?
>> Um, it's in it's in kabad.org. Nabala.
>> Even that name sound familiar? Look,
look, I'll share this tab instead. This
is in kabad.org, a Jewish website. The
torments of the grave. After a person
dies and is buried in the dust of the
earth, four angels immediately arrive
deep in his grave to the height of men
as it says in the treaties perkat.
Pretty good uh pretty good uh
then they restore his soul's body just
like during his lifetime since the
remains connected to both.
>> I got some pretty good Hebrew, huh?
>> Yeah, that's pretty good. I'm proud of
you. No idea if I'm saying it right.
>> Yeah, man. I'm a Hebrew uh expert, so
you you good?
>> Yeah. I got to make sure I say it right.
>> So So what what you think so far, man?
Muhammad copying stories that he heard
and they're calling him out like, "Man,
we all we heard this stuff before, man.
You ain't you ain't you ain't giving us
no revelation, man." You see it? You see
they're they're calling him out for
being a a false prophet. And then yet
other people still get deceived and
duped into believing he's a prophet. It
happens as Jesus already warned us, man.
>> Yep.
>> Uh how how uh how about that? The the
Mormon guy.
>> Same.
>> Joseph Smith.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. He he claims to be in line with
Genesis and he creates his own verses to
add him into Genesis. He created seven
more verses in Genesis to add his name
onto there. Yeah. But
>> what what is he what is he saying?
>> He's saying he's prophesied in Genesis,
but he had to add his own name and add
seven extra verses into Genesis.
>> It's known.
>> But my my my question is right like
Joseph Smith like what what time was he
born?
>> 1800s, something like that,
>> right? So this was like back in the day
like the literacy rate wasn't that high,
but there were people who could read the
Bible. So what what on what basis did he
add these verses to to to Genesis?
>> He made them up. What do you mean he
made it up?
>> You know what his basis was?
>> He got a revelation from an angel and
told him he's a prophet and that he's
prophesied in the previous scriptures.
That's the revelation he got. Does that
sound familiar,
>> Sully?
>> Oh, he's thinking Sully.
>> Yeah,
>> that sound familiar, right?
>> Sounds familiar.
So, so yeah. Yeah, I I hear you guys.
>> Muhammad meets all the criteria
of a false prophet, dude. All of them.
Just like Joseph Smith and just like
others along with them in their same
class that have done the same thing.
Muhammad is nothing new. He's not
unique. And Jesus told us this was going
to happen. Now the thing for us is to do
is the thing for us to do is is to heed
the words of Jesus. Use him as our
foundation so that we are not deceived.
If Christ is our foundation, we believe
in Christ's words. When he says, "I am
the truth. Anything that goes against
him, we won't be deceived. We We're all
right. We good."
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I hear you. Sie,
imagine I was to tell a Jew, hey, Christ
is prophesied to be the Messiah in the
Old Testament, in the Tanah, but only
the parts that agree with us. All the
other parts that looks like he's not the
Messiah, we're going to say is
corrupted. Do you think they would take
us seriously?
>> No. But but uh then the you know the uh
the difference is that uh Christianity
evolves from from uh from Judaism. So
like the guys like Paul were
>> it's a continuation. They're they're
pointing back to the Old Testament
saying this is true and he is truly the
Messiah. He was truly prophesied and
there's a continuation.
But we have we have Muhammad coming
>> and he's not in even in line with
Christ. Not even in line with the
previous prophet.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I I hear I hear you guys.
>> Got you, man.
>> Think on this, man.
>> Yeah. And uh it looks uh looks a bit
looks a bit uh suspicious.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm Yeah. Looks looks looks a bit
suspicious, right?
>> I'm gonna Yeah. Well, we we we love you,
Sully. We And this is why we're doing
this, bro. This is this is why I gave
you, you know, I usually stop my streams
>> at three hours, bro. But you for the my
past few streams have been extending me
to 5 hours, man. You're always my last
guest. You know that, right? And you
extend me to to a few more hours
because, you know, uh I don't know, man.
God has drawn me to you, bro. I I I like
you, man. Um you're cool. We got a good
rapport. and you think and you you're
you're honest with this stuff. So stay
like that and take like dude, cling to
the truth. You see how sus this looks.
You see how sus this is. You you you're
you're able to even rethink and
re-evaluate what you believed at first
and and even adapt. You you you're able
to do that. A lot of people aren't able
to do that, but man, that you're seeing
this stuff and don't don't go under the
guise of you, you were misguided. No,
you're smart enough, you're intellectual
enough, and you're consistent enough to
see the problems, okay? Cling to Christ.
He's the one that you He will never have
you the what you're feeling right now.
He'll never have you feeling like this.
This this question mark, this uh man
like this Jesus seems suspicious.
Absolutely. You will never have any
reason to doubt him.
>> Never.
>> But you know, I
Why why do why did the uh why didn't the
the disciples write it write it down
when he was alive?
>> Well, when Jesus was alive, they they
were just they're on the move
constantly. They didn't have time to sit
down and write. They're on the move. You
know, even even Jesus says that, you
know, like uh what's that verse, DJ?
story says that a fox doesn't have
anywhere to lay its head, you know, and
a and a prophet doesn't have anywhere to
lay his head, not even in his own home,
his own hometown, right?
>> Yeah. Foxes and dens.
>> Yep. Foxes and dens, right? That means
that they're traveling and going from
den to den, hole to hole.
>> But the son of man doesn't have anywhere
to lay his head. That's 8:20.
>> Yeah. To to write one, you got to get
the material. You got to get the money.
You got to get the material for for um
and then you need the time to write.
They didn't they didn't have n that you
know when Jesus was here it was about
listening and doing the work once Jesus
ascended and then now they're
establishing the church even even this
is why it took decades because even in
the beginning of the church explosion
they're on the run
>> they're being chased all over the place
they got to coordinate meetings to get
to each other and send each other
letters you know what I'm saying that so
they got coordinate to get the funds,
have somebody set up the funds for them,
buy the material, go get the material,
and find a safe place to write. This is
why it took a long time. So, um, that
that's that's why you got to put into
perspective the context of what was
going on with the apostles and and and
what was going on around them
>> um for why they why and when they wrote,
>> right? And it also wasn't even about
them writing anything down as Jesus was
there as as they're saying. It's about
what they were doing. Jesus wasn't
coming around saying, "Hey guys, gather
around me and write down everything that
I say the moment I say it." It's about
the mission. That's what they were
focused on. Not, you know, you know,
getting paper and pen and, you know,
jotting things down as soon as it came
out of his mouth. They had they had a a
a hyperfocus on what Jesus was there to
do and accomplish and what they had to
do after he was gone.
>> Yep. And here's uh one last thing on
that too is that Jesus talks about how
when he ascends and when he leaves, he's
not going to leave them as orphans, the
apostles.
>> Exactly.
>> He's not going to leave them as orphans.
Um but he says, "I will come to you."
And in that he's sending them the Holy
Spirit. And watch what the Holy Spirit
does for them when he says he's sending
the Holy Spirit. He says, "Hold on, let
me fix this real quick on Tik Tok. They
trying to ban me. Let me fight it." It
says over here, John chapter 14, it
says, "But the helper," or let me
actually say, "These things I have
spoken to you while I am still with you.
But the helper, the Holy Spirit, whom
the Father will send in my name, he will
teach you all things and bring to your
remembrance all that I have said to you.
Right?
>> So, we're not just relying on just mere
like men in their mere memory. You know,
the Holy Spirit inspired and guided
these men in remembering what Christ
said um and and and to and to document
it. Yep. We even have Christ saying
something similar in uh Matthew 23
23 um 34.
>> Therefore, I send you prophets, wise
men, and scribes, some of some of whom
you will um un alive and crucify, and
some of you will fogg in the synagogues.
>> So, he's going to send out prophets and
scribes. And then and then of course as
Avery just read he's going to send the
Holy Spirit to bring all remembrance so
that you may be led into all truth.
>> Here's an example. Here's an example.
Sie in John 2 19 to22 it says Jesus
answered them destroy this temple and in
3 days I will raise it up. The Jews then
said it was it has taken 46 years to
build this temple and you will you raise
it up in 3 days. But he, this is John
talking now, but he was speaking about
the temple of his body. When therefore
he was raised from the dead, his
disciples remembered that he had said
this and they believed the scripture and
the word that Jesus had spoken. So we
got few examples where we're seeing this
right through the writings where they're
remembering what Jesus said and like,
"Oh, there it is right there. I remember
that man. Hell yeah. When did you say
that? All of this is through the Holy
Spirit.
>> Not not not oral recitation.
>> Not the miracle of recitation.
>> Nah.
>> Memorization.
>> Miraculous memory.
>> Yeah. So,
>> does he speak?
>> What? He's He's just He's chilling. He's
just thinking.
>> Okay.
>> What's crazy? What's crazy about that
passage is even the enemies even the
enemies remember that sort of passage.
And like in Matthew 27 uh40 he said and
saying you would destroy the temple
rebuild it in three days save yourself
if you are the son of God come down from
the cross.
>> So we have both the scribes um you know
the scribes of Christ his disciples and
then we have the enemies of Christ
remembering what he would say. So how
much more would the how much more would
the apostles remember what he would say
after like he sends them the Holy Spirit
if even the enemies of Christ are
remembering what he's saying?
>> That's the truth. still with us, Ollie?
>> I'm here, man. You
>> You all right, man? Yeah.
Uh,
yeah, man. Uh,
look, that was uh Yeah, you've given me
uh a lot to to think about. I'm going to
look into all you've said. I'm gonna
look at the the Mormon the Mormon guy as
well
>> and see see if it uh see if it matches
up, you know. But yeah,
>> if if uh you know if if the prophet if
the prophet is uh is false, then look
around is false, you know.
>> That's right. Well, think think about
this solid. We we'll be praying for you,
man. We'll be praying for you. Um here's
here's a good Thank you. 100 a good if
you want to look into Joseph Smith and
his claims and also some criticisms
there's a YouTube channel called testify
testify and he has done videos going
over Joseph Smith's claims and you can
check him out on there and see uh see
what he was saying and doing. Okay, but
again you you know me, bro. You you're
welcome to my stream anytime. You keep
coming back. Keep coming back. Don't
don't stop coming, bro. I want to I want
to keep building with you, man. We we bu
we building from stream to stream to
stream, man. And uh I'm I'm praying for
you, man. And uh I care about you, bro.
So, I can hear like I I can hear it in
your voice. You know, you kind of a
little let down.
>> But I want you to I want you to
understand, man. Christ says, "Let not
your hearts be troubled, bro. Let not
your hearts be troubled." In John 14:1,
he says, "Let not your hearts be
troubled. Believe in God, believe also
in me. That's what he says. Be
encouraged. Don't be afraid. Okay? So,
you're not lost when you recognize a
falsehood in Muhammad in the Quran. You
are not lost, bro. Christ is the way,
man. As you as we see, you hear me say
all the time. He says, "I'm the way. I
am the truth and I am the life. No one
comes to the father except through me."
You hear his words, you have life. you
believe in him, you have life. No
despair. Okay? So, just want to leave
you with that, man. I'll be live, you
know, when I'm live Monday, Wednesday,
Friday, bro. Come anytime. I don't care
what the topic is. I don't care if I'm
not dealing with Muslims that day. You,
if I see you, I'm pulling you up. All
right, man.
>> All right. God bless you, bro. Praying
for you, man.
>> It's not easy finding out, you know, you
following a false prophet. A lot of
these people are born into it and just
taught this for years. So, you know,
>> it's tough realizing you've been told a
lie for an ample amount of years.
>> Yeah, it's
>> tough.
>> Yeah. I think it's interesting. I think
what's really getting him is the is the
comparisons. You just see the pattern of
what a false prophet is.
>> Yeah.
>> And I didn't want to give him too much
information. Could have given him more,
but just didn't want to overwhelm him.
the constant pattern, you know, the
false prophet will come and say, "Hey, I
actually have the true I actually have
the true scripture." But um and Joseph
Smith, he said, "God has revealed to me
that we can have polygamy and I can have
multiple wives." And in fact, he had a
young wife, too. I mean, he slept with
somebody that's kind of underage. Mhm.
>> And so he he was able to take advantage
of his so-called prophethood and he
added things to the Bible to say, "Hey,
I'm in I'm in the previous scriptures.
I'm prophesied about." Sounds familiar.
>> Love that dude, man. It just it it
breaks it breaks my heart um hearing his
heart be broken like that, you know?
Like he he's if you guys have heard if
you guys have heard you guys seen um the
streams, he's been coming. He's
literally been coming on the past like
three four streams and all of our
conversations as you saw even in the
beginning it's very energetic. It's fun.
We're laughing
>> and stuff like that and serious but you
know we having a good time and you know
>> um
you know to to hear that like that's
that's just what Satan does, man. He
gives people this falsehood. Gives
people this falsehood and um and it
causes heartbreak. It causes turmoil. It
causes despair, all this kind of stuff.
And the opposite of what Jesus is, the
opposite of Jesus. Jesus says, "I am the
light. Those in me walk not in darkness,
but in life, in newness of life." This
is it's the opposite of who Jesus is.
You heard it in his voice. But I
guarantee you guys remember that sound
of his voice that you heard you heard
the was crushed, the pain, the despair,
like let down, man. Disappointment.
remember that sound because when he
comes to Christ, it's going to be a
whole new sound.
>> Amen.
>> It's going to be a whole new sound. The
way he's the way he is going to be
rejuvenated, the way he's going to be
replenished, uh, man, how the spirit is
going to fill him with a joy unlike any
other and a peace like like no other.
I'm telling you guys, man, come to
Christ, man. He is the answer. He's the
answer. You do not have to sit in this.
You don't you do not have to sit in
this. Come to Christ. Cling to him.
>> Uh yeah, Logic. It's been it's been a
turbulent week for me as you know, but
you know, I feel I feel as if I've left
Islam, you know,
>> and uh
>> yeah, man. It's it was so like after
after our stream I went to do some
research into the similarities between
Joseph Smith and uh and the prophet
>> um the prophet right and you know I I
just search it on Google on YouTube and
the first person who pops up was uh was
David Wood. Now, I hate David Wood,
right? I swear to God that I would never
watch him because he's a blasphemer.
But, you know, some I just watched it,
man. And it was it was disturbing. You
know, it was the it was disturbing and
there was there was a particular verse
that he quoted that he was laughing at
>> that got me so mad. But when I looked at
the verse, I was just like, I mean, it
just really
uh it just really made me upset. But
it's correct. It was Quran 33:53.
>> Yeah.
>> It was uh I think that was the last
straw for me because
uh it just couldn't be it just didn't
look divine anymore. You understand?
>> Yeah.
>> So, I'm out. I'm out of uh I don't think
I'm a Muslim. I I haven't even fasted
since Monday, you know. So, yeah. But I
still I still I still got some questions
cuz I' also been reading into uh
Christianity and I got so many
questions, man. But yeah, I'm I'm I'm
out.
>> Praise God.
>> Praise God, man. Wow. That's one I want
to There's a few things I want to say,
bro. Number one, it's tough. It's tough,
bro. It's tough because you know when
you wholeheartedly believe something um
and you know you're in this process
where it's like dang the evidence is
being brought that wow what I've been
believing is actually this isn't this
isn't the truth. It's it's hard. It's
it's not easy to take that um and to
take the next step to have the integrity
and honesty with yourself, with your
soul, with your spirit, and with truth
to say, "I cannot be a part of this
anymore because it's it's just not the
truth. I know it's uncomfortable,
whatever, but I and who cares? I can't
be a part of this anymore." That that
has you so much courage, man. So much
courage. It's brave. It's courageous.
And so I want to just give you your
flowers right now for that move for um
prioritizing truth over familiarity and
comfortability,
you know, cuz I I man it broke it. I've
been thinking about you all week, dude.
And not not know, you know, no, you
know, crazy, but you know, you've been
you've been on my mind and my wife's
mind. We've been thinking about you all
week. And um like even it's funny life
came over the other day. He came over
and we were talking in the middle of our
conversation, bro. I zoned out and was
just thinking of man I wonder what what
Sully's doing right now. I wonder how
he's how is he? I was thinking about
you, bro. In the middle of our
conversation,
>> man. Like I it was difficult for me,
man. like on on Tuesday like man I
really I really couldn't get out of bed
because I started having thoughts right
it like Mormonism right is it doesn't
have that many members but if uh if the
prophet is is not real right and
>> you have over a billion people 1 point
something billion people approaching two
billion people following this I was I
was almost in tears man because
>> my my granddad who I loved
um two years ago he died as a Muslim
>> and uh if Christianity is true then I'll
never get to see him again.
>> Yeah.
>> So it's just disappointing. My parents
they're they're not very uh religious
but they're Muslims. My girlfriend she's
a Muslim. I wanted to marry her.
>> Like it's really it's really affected so
many things.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> But at the end of at the end of the day
when when you see it,
>> you can't unsee it.
>> You can't unsee it.
>> You can't unsee it. It's It's And I, you
know, on on Tuesday, I just
>> even though like I I'm not a Christian.
I'm not a Christian yet cuz I still have
questions. But
>> yeah,
>> I just I just prayed. I said, "God, if
truly Jesus is God and I have said all
my life that he's a prophet, forgive me.
If Paul is your messenger and I've
insulted him and I said he's changed
scriptures, forgive me because these
things were done in ignorance.
>> Yeah.
>> I was reading about the life of Paul and
you know I was upset. I was like this
man you know he sacrificed so much and
uh for me to say that he corrupted
things is is not fair. But I had to say
that you know for my religion I had to
make those claims. understand it. It's
it's just it's I it's it's so difficult
to argue, man. Like I like three times
and every time I was getting rinsed
because like it's hard, bro. Every time
I got to go and change what I believe. I
have to like do so much, you know,
gymnastics. Have to beat shakes. and my
shakes, you know, they they give me
these answers.
>> Like it's it's like one one billion
people, bro.
>> One billion people.
>> Like I I've done bad things in my life,
right? I'm not a person with a squeaky
clean record, but man, being like these
things that guys like Joseph Smith do
for the prophet, it's it's way too far.
Because if Christianity is true and
people are are following this, this is
the height of evil. I don't even know if
I don't know if God can even forgive
them, right? It's too much.
>> Yeah. Um and that's that's why you see
so much passion from, you know, people
like me on this end. David, even David
Wood, who you know, you you know, he was
like, "Man, I hate this guy." But you
you see why we have the energy towards
Islam and and Mormonism that we do
because of the evil deception and the
practices that it leads people into the
stuff it advocates for. It's absolutely
evil, man. It's absolutely evil. And
people are deceived into this stuff.
They're deceived into Islam, duped into
Mormonism and into other cults,
Jehovah's Witness, all all these other
cults, bro. people are deceived into
them. Which is why we are as passionate
and have the energy that we do because
we want you guys to have the true Jesus,
the holy, pure, divine son of God who
you will never have to defend his
morals. You'll never have to defend
Christ, bro. You'll never have to have
to stick up for Christ. Christ's
character stands up for his for his own
self. You never have to defend what he
did, anything he does. He is the
example. He is the standard, you know,
and so we imitate Christ. We try to love
like he does. We He loves absolutely. We
fail in the way that we love. We fail in
the love that we honor each other, that
we honor the needy, that we honor even
those who hate us and our enemies. Jesus
even loved his enemies, prayed for his
enemies. While he's bloodied on the
cross, he said, "Father, forgive them
for they don't know what they're doing."
Right? So that type of character, that
type of love, this is the love of the
God who we serve, who condescends, who
comes down to our level to reach us
because we couldn't reach up to him. We
were not worthy or capable of reaching
him or meeting his standards. So he came
down to us to grab us and take us to
himself. That's the God that we serve,
brother. completely different from
anything that you'll ever see in any in
any other religion, any cult.
>> But logic, I wanted to ask you a
question on like uh cuz my the issue of
my granddad has really been bugging me.
Is there any way that uh a Muslim could
go to heaven, right? Let's say he never
heard um the gospel.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Is it possible? because my my
granddad uh I mean he was aware of
Christianity but I don't know if it was
ever really preached to.
>> Yeah. So um I got to be real with you
man. I got to be real with you. So the
honest truth is that Jesus says that
he's the way. He's the truth. He's the
life. No one comes to the father except
through him. Right? And so Jesus makes
it clear that those who deny him he will
also deny. Right? And as sad as that is
for our loved ones who have been
deceived and follow other things and
rejected Christ in their lifetime,
they've rejected they've rejected him.
And if they die rejecting him, he's he
gives them what they wanted, a life an
an eternity without him,
>> you know. Um
if you're if you're if you're ask Go
ahead.
>> Like this is like this is this is what
really trips me, man. because
>> he was he was a good man. It wasn't his
fault, right? You were born into these
things, bro. Right. That's like at the
end of the day, it's the fault of of the
prophet, right, for starting this. Why?
It should be the prophet who bears the
punishment for this.
>> Well, his punishment is his punishment
is greater than anyone that follows him
for sure. But um it it is also we do
have a responsibility, my brother, as
cuz we are our own individual thinking
human beings. You know, it's like for
example, um if I deceived someone into
stealing, right, and they go out and
steal, right? They still committed the
sin of stealing. My sin is even greater
though because I deceived them into
stealing and, you know, misled them into
stealing. So, that'll be on me. But they
did sin. They did sin and steal, commit
the crime themselves, you know. So in
the same way we are all accountable for
our sin and and our rejection of the
gospel our sin against God whether you
know it's non-belief or you know
whatever lying adultery lust whatever it
is we still have our sin that we have to
be accounted for you know so your
grandfather I don't know I don't know I
don't know him obviously I don't know
every inch of his life I don't know if
he's um come in and encountered the
gospel or not heard of Jesus or not? I'm
pretty I I think would it be safe to say
that he did have some encounters with
Christians and the topic of Jesus and
you know stuck with Islam?
>> So my my parents are uh originally from
Nigeria, right? So my my granddad was
born during the time where Nigeria was
still a British colony, right? So, it's
it's difficult because like the the
missionaries were instructed
uh kind of like not to preach to Muslims
because they didn't want to uh start um
like revolts like they were mainly
instructed to preach to pagans. Well, my
my my granddad would have known about
Christianity at least, but he he may not
have fully understood it. But
>> I just don't know if anyone like
preached to him, right? I doubt anyone
did because of the laws that were placed
at that time.
>> Sure. Okay. So if that if that is the
situation
um I I was informed that like with like
the the early church would say that it's
not they don't have a position on that
necessarily, but that you know God is
just. And so, um, like it's it's not for
us to be able to make a final decision
like, oh yeah, no, it's over for that
dude or whatever. But God God is just in
in all situations. And so, um,
you know, God knowing your your granddad
and the in his situation and, you know,
his scenarios and in his and his
encounters, God will deal with your
granddad justly at the end of the day,
you know. So, I don't necessarily have
the answer to that particularly because
if he wasn't preached to, if he never
heard the gospel, well, then it's just
simply just relying on God's justice,
you know.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I can't I can't necessarily answer
that.
>> Yeah, man. But, uh, you know, at the end
of the day, God alone knows.
>> Yep.
>> You do you do important work. Your wife
does important work. even even someone
who I who I hate like uh Wood Shamoon
all those guys it like at the end of the
day I've I've I've kind of like softened
on it because
>> if you come from the perspective that
this is a this is an evil ideology then
I can I can understand why they they get
kind of extreme at times because you
know there there are things in Islam
that are also extreme you know There's
the the marriage to to Aisha.
There's the there's many things in the
in the Islamic corpus that are also
morally wrong. So, I I can I can get why
these guys are can be that way. So, you
know, bro, keep you know, keep doing
what you're doing. But, you know, yeah,
I still I still got questions, man. Um,
so like I got I got like four or five
main questions, bro. Like so like this
whole week I've been uh I've been
looking into the Trinity, right? Right.
More and more into the Trinity. Um
and every time I try and like understand
the Trinity, it always leads to a
heresy. So like right now I'm kind of
like stuck on modalism
>> because do you wait? Let me ask you. Do
you do you think that uh Jesus and the
father are equal? Yes, they're equal in
their essence. Yes.
>> So why is Jesus called the son?
>> Because he is begotten from the father.
He comes forth from the father, right?
And so that is why he is I called the
son. That's why he is known as the son
of the father. And so notice but being
the son of the father means that he has
the same nature of his father. Right? So
because the father's nature and essence
is infinite eternal it's it's divine the
son also has the nature of divinity he's
divine he's eternal he's infinite
>> but so wait so Jesus Jesus is is
infinite but he died
>> right so dying doesn't mean that you
cease to exist si so dying is just that
you're you're you're uh you're
separating from you know it's a
separation of body and soul, right?
That's all death is. And that only
happens if you have a if you have a
physical if you have a body to separate
from. So what Christ did was is that he
took on flesh, right? He took on a human
nature because he couldn't he couldn't
experience death in his divine nature.
So he took on a human nature in which he
can experience death on our behalf and
therefore have experience that that
phenomenon where the body and the soul
separate you know and so his soul just
goes to a different realm right so it's
not he doesn't cease to exist never he
is he always existed
>> but like using that logic wouldn't all
human beings be immortal because we all
have souls
>> well so when you when you when you're
saying immortal you talking about
immortal mortality or or mortality. When
you're talking about mortality, you're
talking about being a able to experience
death, right? You have a physical body
that that um you know deceases, right?
Jesus was only able to experience death
by taking on a human nature. Okay? And
so um but even even so, like if you're
talking about humans, humans don't cease
to exist when they die. You just move to
another another plane, right? you you
you separate from your body. That's
that's what death is. So when you talk
about mortality, it's it's having a
physical body that can experience death
or not.
>> Yeah. So I think what I'm trying to ask
is is Jesus's human nature equal to God?
>> Is his human nature equal to God?
>> Yeah.
>> No. No. So like what we would say is is
that so the person of Christ he is equal
to the father through his divine nature
because he and the father have the same
divine nature that's where they are
equal right Jesus takes on a human
nature right and and if you're talking
about via his human nature he wouldn't
be equal to the father in that sense
>> right okay
>> so so it's two different when you're
talking about Jesus you always got to
remember
>> that there's a point in time where it
becomes both and not either or it's both
and because Jesus has two natures that
he t he has divine nature and he has a
human nature right so in the human
nature he submits to the father he
humbles himself to the father you know
that that becomes that dynamic but
regarding his divine essence his divine
nature he's equal with the father which
is which is why the bible says this if
you um we go to Philippians 2 the the
bible breaks this down pretty good
Actually, we go to Philippians chapter
2. It talks about having the mindset of
humility, and it uses Jesus as an
example, right? And it's really good.
Let me show you this really quick. So,
Philippians 2,
um, let's see here. This is Paul
writing, by the way. says, "Therefore,
if there is any encouragement in Christ,
if there is any consolation of love, if
there is any fellowship of the spirit,
if any affection and compassion, fulfill
my joy, that you think the same way by
maintaining the same love, being united
in spirit, thinking on one purpose,
doing nothing from selfish ambition or
vain glory, but with humility of mind,
regarding one another as more important
than yourselves. Right? So the context
is having humility. Right?
Not merely looking out for your own
personal interest but also for the
interests of others.
Have this way of thinking in yourselves
which was also in Christ Jesus. So
Christ also this humility this humble
mindset is what Christ had and explains
how who although existing in the form of
God right so he was God had the nature
of God did not regard equality with God
a thing to be grasped meaning something
to hold on to something he couldn't let
go but he had to hold on to that
equality no he let that equality go
right he set that aside right it says
So even though he existed in the form of
God, he did not regard equality with God
a thing to be grasped, something to hold
on to, but emptied himself by taking the
form of a slave, being made in the
likeness of men. Being found in
appearance as a man, he humbled himself
by becoming obedient to the point of
death, even death on a cross. All right?
So you see where Jesus exists in the
form of God. He has a divine nature.
He's equal with the father via his
divine nature. But he doesn't hold on to
that equality to that glory, right? To
that status. He lets that go to and
takes on the form of a servant and takes
on human form, right? And becomes
obedient to the father even to the
humiliating death on a cross. This is
the type of humble mindset that Christ
had. So remember when you're talking
about Christ, it's both and not either
or. He has two natures.
>> All right. Uh logic. So with all this
being said, like what's the issue with
modalism? Like why is it wrong?
>> Yeah. So so modalism teaches that Christ
and the father are the same person. Not
just that they have the same nature in
essence, but that they are the same
person. They're one and the same person.
So g basically they're saying Jesus is
the father and the holy spirit is the
father and is Jesus. like they're all
just one person, just different modes of
God, right? Not three distinct persons
that exist, coexist together in harmony,
united in the essence. They don't. So
that's why it's wrong because Christ is
clearly not the father. He says that,
you know, we clearly see him speak to
the father. He says the father sent him,
right? Um the holy spirit, he says that
he is the one who sends the holy spirit
from the father. So Jesus makes a clear
distinction between himself, the father,
and the spirit. Like they're distinct
persons, right? Jesus says um for
example, he says um according to your
law, cuz the Jews were questioning him,
right? They're saying your testimony is
not valid, right? This is in John
chapter 8. And Jesus says, "Well,
according to your law, isn't it in your
law that the testimony of two witnesses
makes a testimony valid?" Right? makes a
witness valid. He says, "I testify. I am
one who testifies of myself. I'm one
witness and the father is another
witness who bears witness who testifies
of me." Clearly making the distinction.
He's one witness. The father is another.
So they can't be the same person. And
that's where modalism goes wrong. Does
it make sense?
>> Yeah, man.
>> Yeah. But uh also like uh again another
thing is like uh why exactly uh did
Jesus have to die like because God God
is God is omnipotent uh omnipotent right
>> omnipotent all powerful yeah that's
right
>> yeah so he could have he could have
forgiven the sins of the world without
the sacrifice. So
>> uh no
>> he couldn't have
>> no I'm tell you why God being all
powerful means that he has no flaws. He
has no lack, right? He is completely
sufficient in every way possible, right?
He's self-sufficient. That means that
God is also just,
>> correct? He's just and he's holy. Would
you agree?
>> Yeah.
>> So God being perfect means he's
perfectly just and he cannot be unjust.
Right? So for example, let me ask you
this. If I robbed a bank,
>> Yeah.
>> I got caught. I'm in the courtroom.
Judge caught me on camera, man. They see
my handsome face on the camera with the
money bags. Judge says, "Man, what do
you have to say for yourself?" I say,
"Man, judge, I'm sorry. I repent of what
I did. I will never do this again." Will
the judge let me go?
>> Will the judge let you go? No.
>> If he did let me go because I repented
and said, "I'm sorry," would he be just?
>> No.
>> Nope. So notice if even an earthly judge
recognizes justice and has to perform
justice in his judgment when people
break crimes and just because they say
they sorry and can be can genuinely be
sorry. They can't just let you go
because the crime was committed. The
crime has to be dealt with. It has to be
paid for. So a just judge cannot just
let you go because you're sincerely
sorry. He has to punish crime. He has to
deal with the sin. He has to deal with
the crime. So even more, infinitely more
is the just judge of heaven and earth.
God, the almighty God, the holy,
perfect, pure judge of the of the of the
universe. He is infinitely just. And so
he can't just sweep sin under the rug.
He can't just sweep our crime under the
rug just because we are sincerely sorry.
Sin still has to be dealt with. the
crime still has to be dealt with. And
according
>> before uh before Jesus came, how were
sins forgiven?
>> Right? So good question. Before Christ
came, God implemented a system of
substitutionary atonement or sacrificial
atonement. So look, for example, if we
go to Romans 5 up, let me go to
Leviticus 17:11, right? Leviticus 17:11.
And this is what this is what uh God
says. He says, now remember this is Old
Testament. This is Moses time, right?
>> He says, "For the life of the flesh is
in the blood, and I have given it to you
on the altar to make atonement for your
souls. For it is the blood that makes
atonement by the life." So, according to
God's system, according to God's law,
death uh and blood sacrifice, blood
atonement is the um way to cover your
sin or to make atonement for your sin.
Now, here's the thing. These sacrificial
lambs, bulls, and oxes, and you know,
all that kind of stuff, incense burning,
that stuff was only temporary, which is
why they had to do this all the time.
They had to continuously sacrifice bulls
and goats and lambs and stuff. They had
to continuously do this because that
wasn't good enough. So what this was all
a foreshadowing, a setup for what God
was going to ultimately do, the ultimate
sacrifice in himself through the through
the son, the Messiah. And this is what
he says here. Let's go to uh let's put
in Ezekiel Ezekiel 16. Let's do uh
62-63.
Watch this Bible. Okay, so that's that.
Watch Ezekiel 16 62- 63.
>> Oh, why did it split it up? Oh, come on.
Uh, I didn't push 63. And my mouse is
tripping right now. My bad, bro. Just uh
bear with me. 62. Oh, I said 62.
It was made to appear that I put 63. All
right. It says, "Thus," this is Yahweh
speaking. "Thus I will establish my
covenant. Thus I will establish my
covenant with you, and you shall know
that I am Yahweh, so that you may
remember and be ashamed and never open
your mouth anymore because of your
dishonor when I have atoned for you, for
all that you have done, declares Yahweh,
the Lord Yahweh. So you, he's saying,
you can't do it. You can't atone for
what you've done. You can't atone for
your sins. But guess what? I'm going to
do it. I myself am going to atone for
your sins, for all that you've done.
Right? This is all set up and
foreshadowing the ultimate atonement,
the ultimate sacrifice which God himself
is going to do when he comes in the
flesh in the person of Christ and give
his
>> life. Yeah. Go ahead.
>> This is this is the Old Testament.
>> This is Old Testament. But man, this is
Ezekiel chapter 16. This is Old
Testament. way before way before any
Paul or Peter or Matthew, you know, this
is Old Testament establishment, man.
>> Yeah. Interesting. Uh yeah, I'm going to
write down this verse, but logic um
there are now that we dropping those
questions out of the way.
>> There are still two things that have
really prevented me from converting to
uh Christianity completely, right?
Because like now that I'm out of Islam,
obviously the next logical step for me
was to become a Christian because it was
Christianity which did bring me out of
Islam.
>> Yeah.
>> But before I asked those two questions,
like there's something more personal
like so if I do become a Christian, um
my girlfriend
>> Yeah.
>> Uh
what what what could I what could I do
there?
>> Teach her the same thing you learned.
the same thing that you learned,
everything that you learned so far, and
then continue to study and learn, and
give her the gospel, bro. The greatest
thing that you can give to anyone, your
girlfriend, your parents, your uh you
said you had siblings, too, that were
Muslim.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Your siblings, everybody in your
community, bro.
>> My my like my family was not really
religious, but I became more religious
in the past like four or five years, but
my family is not really religious. Like
my even my girlfriend, he's she's more
religious than my family, but she's
still she's still a Muslim,
>> right? And uh I I don't know. I don't
know. It's it's uh if I do become a
Christian, what if she doesn't accept
Christianity? Could I could I uh pretend
to be a Muslim?
>> Cuz like no one no one knows about that.
No one else like no one in my personal
life knows that I've kind of become an
apostate. So like everyone still thinks
I'm fasting and stuff.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, so this is this is
the outlook, brother. Becoming a
Christian is you are making Jesus Christ
the Lord of your life, right? You're
serving the true God. He is your Lord.
Your Lord meaning he is the one in whose
hand is your life. You serve him above
all else. You know, you please him. You
seek the honor and the pleasure of your
Lord rather than man, rather than your
girlfriend, mother and father, you know,
it's your Lord that you serve, not your
girlfriend, not not your family, not
your friends. And so,
um, the best thing that you can do for
these people is give them the gospel.
And and you do this in wisdom, you know,
you do this in wisdom and you're not
going to beat them over the head with it
like like how you and I talk, right?
Like I didn't beat you over the head
with this stuff. We to we we spoke, we
talked, right? Um and it doesn't work
out with everyone all the time. You have
to know that it's it doesn't work out
all the time with everyone, nor does it
work out immediately, you know, like in
our first it wasn't our first three,
four conversations, it didn't it's now
we're here. This is like number six for
for you and me, right? It may take
longer for others, you know. Um, but you
the best thing you could do is be honest
with them. Give them the truth of the
gospel and gradually
show them why Islam is false the same
the same way that you came to know,
right? or even ask them personally what
makes Islam true to them and address
those things in particular to show how
those do not do not fit how those
particular things don't work. Okay.
Learn learn more and be in a position to
be able to teach them. Okay. Um but
pretending to be a Muslim. No, you you
>> so you have to say it openly. There's no
>> if you're if you're n there's no takia.
If if you're asked if you're like you
don't got to go around shouting, "Hey,
I'm I'm a Christian now. I'm a Christian
now." You ain't got to do that. But if
you are asked about your faith, you got
to tell the truth and be honest. You
cannot and you cannot pretend to, you
know, serve another God. You can't you
can't do that. There's no We We live in
truth. We walk in truth, brother. And
and in walking in truth and walking for
the Lord, Jesus tells us, man. Matter of
fact, let me let me just show you what
Jesus says because he man, I'm telling
you, man, Jesus answers everything. He
He warns us of this stuff before we get
ourselves into these situations. I'm
telling you, remember I showed you where
he saw talked about how many false
prophets will come and deceive a lot of
people, how they'll be successful at it.
So, he also says something else. Um um
uh
what's that verse, guys? I was blanking.
It's in Matthew where um mother and
father uh son and daughter, you guys
know the verse. If you deny them for my
uh if you if you choose them over him.
What's that verse, guys? It's it's I'm
I'm having a brain fart. Let me see.
Let's see. Matthew 10. There it is.
Matthew chapter 10. Matthew chapter 10.
Do you have a physical Bible uh yet or
you just read the Bible through the
through the internet?
>> No, I use the Bible app.
>> The Bible app. That's good. Okay. All
right. Matthew chapter 10. Jesus warns
us of persecution and the type of
persecutions we will face. Bro, let's
see.
All right. Here we go. So, this is what
he says here. We'll start at verse 32.
Actually, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We'll start
at verse 32. Therefore, everyone who
confesses me before men, I will also
confess him before my father who is in
heaven. But whoever denies me before
men, I will also deny him before my
father who is in heaven. Right? And so
he says,"Do not think that I've come to
bring peace on earth. I did not come to
bring peace but a sword." And he's about
to clarify what he means by this. Not
war necessarily, but the dividing
between light and darkness, truth and
falsehood. That's what he came to divide
and split up. Right? For I came to set a
man against his father, and a daughter
against her mother, and a
daughter-in-law against her
mother-in-law, and a man's enemies will
be the members of his own household. He
who loves father or mother more than me
is not worthy of me. And he who loves
son or daughter more than me is not
worthy of me. And he who does not take
his cross and follow after me is not
worthy of me. He who has found his life
will lose it. And he who has lost his
life for my sake will find it. He who
receives you receives me, and he who
receives me receives him who sent me. He
who receives a prophet in the name of a
prophet shall receive a prophet's
reward, and he who receives a righteous
man in the name of a righteous man shall
receive a righteous man's reward. Okay?
So he says, so he makes it clear because
of him, because of his name, because of
his truth and his message, households
will be divided because there will be
households that will be split with one
side having the truth and the other side
deceive uh uh in in darkness in
falsehood, right? one side walking in
the light that comes to the light while
the others are in darkness, walking in
darkness freely and remaining in
darkness, loving the darkness, rejecting
the light. So he warns you like he lets
you know ahead of time, man, listen for
your your concern should not be man's
acceptance of you. It better not be
man's acceptance of you. Your your your
concern should not be whether or not I
will lose my friends and family because
whoever loses his life, Christ says,
will gain it. We'll gain it.
>> Yeah, man. Uh logic, look, at the end of
the day, uh I'm blessed with the kind of
parents I have because there are people
who they could they could get disowned
for becoming Christians.
>> Yeah. Uh my parents are Muslims, but
they're not extremists, right? They're
they're kind of like liberal Muslims.
They're liberal Muslims.
>> I'm not really worried about them. It's
just cuz I I had wanted to marry my
girlfriend. That was really the thing
that
>> that was bugging me, right? But yeah,
I'm not so worried about uh my family
splitting up. my my my parents would
they'd be upset, but they don't really
uh hate Christians or anything. They're
not those kind of people. But yeah, that
was the main thing that was bugging me.
But yeah, if I if I do become a
Christian, then the first thing I I'll
do is I'll sit my girl down and I'll
say, "Hey," and I'm going to have to be
aggressive with it
>> because, hey, look, even even if I can't
get her to become uh a Christian, I
mean, I I'll still just have to get her
out of Islam. I think if she leaves
Islam, it would be it would be easier,
right?
>> Yeah, you're absolutely right, brother.
the the the step the and and notice if
you watch me, I always lead with
breaking down the walls of Islam first
and then presenting the gospel. That's
when that's usually when the Muslim is
open to the gospel where all of a sudden
Jesus dying for their sins isn't so hard
to accept anymore or even the Trinity is
it's not so tough of a concept to accept
now that now that Islam is out the way.
It's it's really miraculous what happens
when someone
uh you know releases Islam and how open
to the gospel they become. It's it's
really amazing. Same with you. It's the
same thing that happened to you, bro. So
>> yeah, man. Right. Let's look at the at
the end of the day, right? Uh I I
actually went back and watched some of
our old debates. when you when you leave
uh Islam, you're like, "Wow, I was being
kind of illogical here." I was saying it
was kind of like circular reasoning. You
get me?
>> Um yeah, like Christianity, like
>> look at look at what you just showed me
in Ezekiel, right? That's before that's
before uh like the New Testament even.
>> Yep.
>> You get what I'm saying? Because like
the difference is there's a progression,
right? there's a kind of a clear
progression because like when I when I
when I was a Muslim I always used to
wonder like oh how do people believe
Islam and become Christians right
>> cuz I always felt as if like from my
perspective it was like imagine you
logic becoming a Jew right why are you
going back to an older revelation like
it didn't make sense to me
>> right but like when you when you look at
Christianity and how it developed from
Judaism, there's there's a a
progression. You get what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
>> Right. It's it's more grounded in
reality even if even if you don't accept
uh Christianity because one of the the
things that I was uh that there was uh
that was really like last week or I
think it was two weeks ago where I was
listening to a podcast or like something
about Bartman, right? Mhm.
>> And Bartman said, "Oh, Jesus was
crucified." Or something like I was
like, "Wait, even the atheists are
saying this. I had to change I had to
change my my view on the crucifixion to
fit Islam.
>> I have to do a bunch of mental
gymnastics for it." But I was like,
"Wow, how can man even say this?" Like,
so that's that's that's the difference,
right? Even if someone's not a
Christian, you have to take Christianity
more seriously as a worldview than than
than
Islam, right? Because
>> the way like the the similarities with
Joseph Smith were Yeah.
>> were too much because that's not how
prophets operate in the in the Bible.
They don't come like like you can
correct me if I'm wrong, right? But
there's no prophet who says anything
about corruption in the Bible. Right.
>> That says what?
>> Anything about corruption like corrupted
scripture?
>> No. Yeah. No. No.
>> That's what I'm saying.
>> Right. This whole like corruption thing,
it's so like it doesn't even make sense.
Like why would God uh allow corruption
for so long? It doesn't make sense. And
also the Jews, whatever you think of the
Jews, I know many Muslims don't like
Jews. Uh, but whatever you think of the
Jews, they at least, especially in
antiquity, they had a lot of respect for
their book. They're not going to they're
not going to change things that easily.
>> Yep.
>> You get what I'm saying? So, yeah. But I
Yeah, I still wait I'm wasting time,
man. I still got I still got the things
which are keeping me from becoming a
Christian, bro. But like I just wanted
to say that like yeah like when you look
at Christianity with an open mind it's
way more plausible than the Quran man
you don't find Quran 33:53 you don't
find Jesus saying things like this
>> that uh you don't find Jesus having
multiple wives right like my my granddad
had multiple wives I don't even think
necessarily that polygamy is something
bad but the Quran says four and the
prophet had nine Yep.
>> That's the That's the behavior of a
cult, man.
>> Something that Smith was doing, too.
>> Exactly.
>> You know, when you see these things and
I feel that that's something that
Christian apologists could even utilize
more
>> if you draw these comparisons side by
side.
>> Yeah. Man, it's because like I was
arguing with you about so many things,
but man, when I when I heard that, you
know, Joseph Smith had the same claims
like a millennia after the prophet, I
was like, "Wow."
>> And and successfully grew a following.
>> Yeah, man.
>> Yeah.
>> It's the same thing. It's the It's the
same pattern you'll see with a with the
false prophets. It's the same thing, you
know. Insane. Well, well, Sully, listen.
>> Let me ask these.
>> Yeah. Ask Ask whatever you need, bro.
I'm I'm here. I'm chilling, man. I'm I'm
here to serve.
>> Yeah, man. So, like what my my there two
or three main things are really like
keeping you from converting. So, like my
first question is uh what what do you
think of like young earth creationism?
>> Yeah. So, I I don't I don't believe that
the Bible teaches young earth. Um,
I I I don't see where they get that
from, but um, you know, if they want to
hold that view, they can have that if
they want. You know, it's not going to
put you in
>> No, I'm just I'm just asking you like,
do you believe the earth was created in
>> 6,000 years?
>> 6,000?
>> No. No. I know. I believe it's
definitely longer than that. Yeah.
>> But do you believe that the Earth was
created in a certain number of days?
>> Now, I I I don't know. I I don't know if
it's like uh you know 24-hour days or if
those are like periods or if those are
like six periods that it's talking
about. So I'm not I'm not exactly sure
on that, you know. Um because those
those words can be interpreted in in
different ways and they're used
differently else in other places in the
Bible. So yeah.
>> Yeah, man. The reason I'm saying this is
cuz I I saw like a podcast or something
where a guy was talking. He was saying
that the creation story in Genesis was
metaphorical, right? And I I I just I
was just like, "Wait, hold on." Right?
He said that um it's silly to believe
that God actually rested after uh on the
seventh day. And I and I said, "Hold
on." Right? The whole reasoning behind
the Sabbath is that God did rest on the
seventh day. So you you you can't just
say that, oh this is completely
metaphorical.
>> I agree.
>> Get what I'm saying?
>> Yeah. I agree with you. I don't I don't
think that Genesis one is metaphorical.
I think that it's um a a real creation
event, you know, where God is bringing
about creation. There are certain things
that it's interesting because there's
certain things there's theories where
uh you know cuz God is giving commands
for things to come out instead of him
making them. But he's saying let this
come and let this be this and let this
come out and do this and you know so it
it's it's it's interesting you know it's
it's it's deeper than I think the plain
text reads. I think it's a lot deeper
than the surface level. However, I do
believe that it's an actual genuine
event that took place and um in that
seventh day or that seventh period
whatever that was is uh you know when
God ceased his work he stopped you know
his creative work at that point you know
to where that's why the Sabbath day is
made holy so
>> yeah like my my main issue with the with
Genesis was the scientific fact where it
says the sun was created before the
earth and scientifically we know that
the earth was created no no pardon me it
says the earth is created before the sun
and we know scientifically that's
impossible
>> that's one of the things that's been
causing issues for me
>> yeah so inspireing philosophy he does a
a good video breaking down the Genesis
story the Genesis 1 narrative and um and
and breaking down the deeper literary
elements of Genesis 1 and better
understand it cuz on the surface it's
it's so much deeper than it is on like
under the plain reading of the text. So
check out check out his video on that.
He's texting me right now. Let's see
what he said. Yeah, he has a he has a
playlist. So it's it's the Genesis 1
chapter 1-11 playlist. So it's Genesis 1
to11 playlist on inspiring philosophy.
You you go through that and check that
stuff out and uh I think that that'll be
really good. Give you some good insight.
>> Yeah, man. Uh the second one was
something I discovered when I was a
Muslim when I was trying to prove that
the Bible was corrupted, right? Because
there was a time where you spoke to uh I
was desperate to prove that uh Daniel 2
was about Islam, right?
>> So I I was kind of upset, right? So I
went to do uh more research into the
book of Daniel. And this was the time
where I I was so happy cuz scholars say
that Daniel was written in like 160 BC
that it's a forgery. So I was using that
as an example for the Bible being
corrupted.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Right. And the scholarly consensus is
that Daniel is a forgery. Right. And
Daniel was very theologically important
to the story of Jesus because Jesus does
call himself the son of man and all
that.
>> So wait, are you saying that Daniel is a
forgery? cuz it's it's not
>> that's what that's what the that's what
the scholarly consensus is.
>> What what scholarly consensus?
>> The scholarly consensus is so Daniel uh
claims to be written during the
Babylonian exile, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. What when you say scholarly
consensus like what what scholars are
you are you appealing to that is the
consensus? Cuz I've never seen
>> uh I don't I don't know what's like a
couple of YouTube videos on. It's not
like a deep scholarly work. It's just
like I was watching like a couple of
YouTube videos where they said that oh
the book of Daniel is a forgery because
it it uh it's too accurate if you
understand what I'm saying. It gets if
you if you read the book of I think it's
like Daniel 8 where it talks about like
a shaggy goat or like a rough goat with
a large horn and that's that's clearly
Alexander the Great, right? And it
splits into four. That's these are
clearly like his the deal like his
generals like it's way too accurate on
like that's what the guy would say. Now
for an atheist obviously if something is
too accurate he's going to say oh this
is definitely a forgery right but there
are other things in in the book of
Daniel which point to it being not
actually written at the time that it
claims right because after the time of
like Antiochus I stops being accurate
and the language is also like Aramaic in
late Hebrew which wouldn't have been
used during the Babylonian uh Babylonian
period
And like
are really bothering me.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. According to why wouldn't they why
wouldn't they be using Hebrew in the
Babylonian period?
>> Cuz like it used a lot of like Greek
loan words cuz like uh
>> yeah Greek loan words uh in the book of
Daniel. I I don't speak Hebrew but
apparently uses a lot of like Greek uh
loan words.
>> There's no there's no Greek in the book
of Daniel. What are they talking about?
>> No, no. It it it's written in Hebrew,
but uses Greek loan words. It shouldn't
be there at the time of the Babylonian
exile. So, the the the what I was
watching said that, oh, Daniel was
written under the uh Selius Empire, like
the Greek controlled. Just just really
quick because cuz I I I'm not the type
that I don't chase every random claim
that like people make.
>> Did was there was there evidence that
they like what evidence did they have to
demonstrate that Daniel is late? Daniel
has Greek in it or uses Greek loan
words, whatever that means. What what
what evidence are they giving? Because
>> in the manuscript that we have with the
scrolls that we have, it's Hebrew and
Aramaic. So, what are they what are they
talking about, bro?
>> Yeah. One of the first evidences, quote
unquote, that he used was uh that it's
too accurate, which is not evidence for
me, right? Something being too accurate,
like I believe in prophecy. So, if it's
accurate, that just proves it, right?
But the second thing,
>> they're coming from a presupposition
that the supernatural is not possible.
>> Yeah. And I I don't I don't agree with
that. Right. So,
>> I was The second thing was he was
talking about linguistic evidence. He
was saying that the Hebrew was using
Greek loan words that if the person
under like the the Jews under Babylon
had not really uh come into contact with
Greek culture yet. So there would be no
way for them to be using like Greek loan
words and that it makes starts making
historical mistakes after the rule of
Antiochus before. the guy who kills the
guy who kills the pig on the altar. Like
that's the claim that the uh that the
guy was saying. He was saying that oh
that Daniel was actually written during
the time of like Antiochus and it
doesn't there's no there's no like uh
one of the strongest things he said was
that it appears very late in like the
Hebrew cannon. There's no if it was
really written in like the 600s it
should have appeared earlier. That was
this is like the main thing that's
keeping me from
>> Yeah. So, but what what what evidence is
he bringing though? Because I'm just
hearing claims. I'm not hearing any
evidence given, dude. You know what I'm
saying? I'm hearing
>> linguistic evidence.
>> Yeah, but it's based off a
presupposition like an assumptions like,
"Oh, this wouldn't be this if this is
this." And
>> no, like the pre let's let's throw out
the pre.
>> Just really quick. So um so IP sent me
somebody named Benjamin Newman who shows
that Daniel uses old Persian loan words
and the language fits with an earlier
period. So you have scholars that are
arguing against this this other I guess
this other guy that you're talking on
YouTube who tries to argue that that and
IP you can come up if you want to if you
could explain this better but you have
scholars that are arguing against what
these other scholars are trying to say
that he's using language that doesn't
belong to an earlier period. So I'm just
IP's here. What's up IP? You want to
speak to this because this is
interesting.
>> Oh yeah. We talk about Daniel. Yeah,
it's a good book.
>> Oh yeah. So there there yeah there are a
lot of critical scholars that do date it
to like a later period. Uh which uh you
know not just going to dismiss it
outright. Uh but I mean there's a lot of
interesting data that actually shows
that it is actually early that's not
been addressed by like Benjamin Nan. So
he talks about Greek loan words but
actually Benjamin Nan who's a linguistic
scholar. He's very very very
intelligent. He's gone through Daniel
and he's shown that there's a lot of old
Persian loan words that fit with a very
early time that were not being used
during the cellucid period. So it's like
it's like you find an old English
document that says do thou protest you
had obviously wasn't written today
unless someone was trying to mimic it.
Uh but we would expect that to be uh
with an earlier English time. So there's
that. So there's that kind of data as
well. Uh, so I mean like yeah, there
some of these arguments that a lot of
conservative scholars put out aren't
ever addressed and this is like one of
those things that seems to point Daniel
to an earlier period. As for the uh the
Hebrew and the Aramaic switching, uh,
some scholars have pointed out something
interesting that this might be on
purpose. Uh, so the book of Daniel
starts out with like a Hebrew open and
then it go then it's like in Aramaic I
believe
>> and then it's when you get to Daniel 7
it's still in Aramaic and the rest is in
Hebrew. But if you divide Daniel into
two sections you kind of have like two
little structures like the first half of
Daniel is Hebrew open Aramaic and then
the second half starting in Daniel 7 is
Aramaic open rest in Hebrew. It's it's
designed actually the way the Hebrew and
the Aramaic switch. So yeah, it's it I I
I I
don't think that it's you can say that
everything in Daniel is like cellucid
period. It what may have been happened
and this is the view I'm kind of leaning
towards is that it was compiled at a
later point like in the cell per like
there was a bunch of documents from
Daniel that they had and they're like
whoa this crazy stuff is happening.
let's get all these documents we knew
from this earlier prophet and of Babylon
and then that's when they compiled the
book but there's a lot of huge debates
around the dating of Daniel. It's not
all clearcut as some like to say.
>> Yeah. IP uh look is there any like book
I could read on this right cuz like like
Logic was saying like a YouTube video is
not enough. I I really want to do my own
research into it.
>> Yeah. There's um so there's a guy here
on YouTube his name is his channel is
Sentinel Apologetics. His name is Rod
Row. He has written an entire commentary
on Daniel that is free. Uh I I can get
you the link here. Uh because I def
because he sent it to me as well. So if
you give me a second, I can drop it in
like the private chat for you. Uh so
he's put this entire PDF out here where
he's done this entire commentary. It's
filled with scholarly quotes. Uh very
useful. He the first like entire section
is on like reliability of Daniel. So, if
you give me a second, I'll find that for
you and then I will um you know, you can
have that as well.
>> Cool. Yeah, take your time and try to
get that going.
>> Yeah, that's that's that's quite
interesting though. I'd say like that.
>> Yeah, this idea that it's late. I mean,
like you got like you know, like the
other thing to think about is like for
example, take the the book of Song of
Solomon, like David Carr, for example,
notes, you know, that we have copies of
Song of Solomon in the Dead Sea Scrolls
that have been updated in terms of their
language to fit with that time period.
If all we had was that copy, we would
assume that Song of Solomon was a very
late document. So often they would
update text to fit with later languages.
Like we we we expect this as well with
like the Torah for example and other
documents
>> like I remember reading some scholars in
the book exploring the composition of
the penetuk talk about that. Uh so you
know like Daniel language fits with
>> IP like one one of the things one of the
things this guy was saying was uh like
earlier earlier Jewish uh text like
Ecclesiasticus
doesn't mention Daniel.
>> Oh like Ecclesiastes. No, Ecclesiasticus
like like it's it's a collection of like
Jewish texts talking about like uh
prophets and it was written in like 190
or 200 BC and it doesn't mention Daniel.
That's one of the things he was saying.
>> Yeah.
>> So you were trying to say that even if
it was written early it you're
>> it couldn't it may have not been
accepted into the Jewish canon yet.
>> Yeah. That so yeah that that's entirely
possible. As I said I think it may have
been compiled late. So for example uh
you know like you know I'm trying to
think of a good example here. So like um
think of the collection of Paul's
letters like
>> Paul wrote various letters and then we
know that the early church collected
them and started putting them into like
like different like codexes. We got all
Paul's letters we want to get them all
together and put them in a codex. That
may have been the same thing with Daniel
is that uh you know like they may have
collected it all later point into its
own book. And you know there's a great
scholar named Michael Heiser who passed
away who said I always explain this with
an analogy. I call it the holy stapler
analogy. Let's say the prophet Isaiah
dies. Okay? And it's like oh he's dead.
What are we going to do? And they get
all his sayings together and they go
anybody got a good stapler. No that's
not what you're going to do. You're
going to ask is anybody here good at
writing? We got to take all of Isaiah's
prophecies and weave them into a
coherent book so it makes sense. And
that's what's going on. And if the Holy
Spirit can inspire Isaiah, he can also
help lead the writers of the trident to
make the book coherent and pass it
along. So that that's what's sort of
going on here is like Daniel speaks, he
gives these prophecies, his writings are
collected, and at a later point there,
it's compiled into a coherent book so
the later people can understand it.
>> Yeah. like IP like the atheists are
they're always going to be skeptical
about it because like like I said it's
so it's so accurate that if like there's
there's no logical explanation for it
right from an atheist perspective you
get what I'm saying like like if you
just read Daniel it doesn't seem that
miraculous but when you have historical
context and you actually read the like
explanation of what the author is
talking about it becomes kind of like
scary right you have like perfect
predictions, right? The the main issue
is that like it stops getting accurate
after Antioch is before.
>> Yeah. There there's a lot of stuff and I
I just put the link to Rob two two links
to Rob Rose commentary. He goes through
a lot of stuff, man.
>> Yeah. I mean like so I mean like there's
a whole there's a whole lot of cultural
context in there. It make sure one of
those links works. The second one you
might need to request access and I'll
just let him know and he'll send it to
you.
>> What's his what's his channel again?
>> Sentinel Apologetics.
solder.
All right, man. I'll definitely be
checking this out, bro.
>> Yeah, he cites Benjamin Non in there a
lot. So, that that that's good to get
some good information on Daniel. He's
got some good commentary. He includes a
ton of quotes. Like,
>> h how do you spell how do you spell uh
Benjamin's surname?
>> Oh, Nunan. So, yeah, it's not Newman.
It's I got it wrong when I first said it
to N O N.
Yeah, the paper I'm referring to, I
think, is the presence and significance
of foreign loan words in the book of
Daniel. Riveting title, uh, but very
very rip packed with good information.
>> Yeah, man. It's the It's the kind of
like autistic I love.
>> I love to read.
>> Yeah, me too. Me, too. I do that stuff
all the time.
>> All right, man. I I'll check that out,
man. I'll check that out. Uh if you're
if you're like maybe like a couple of
weeks like after I've read this stuff
like cuz I like if you're having a live
I I'd like love to talk to you.
>> Oh, sure.
>> Yeah. I try to um I try to go live on my
channel on Thursdays. So I'm not
competing with Avery here. So if you
want to call in then not like we can set
like if you would call back in again and
Avery just text me and if I'm free I'll
just jump in or something.
>> Yep.
>> All right, bro. Yeah, no problem.
Thanks.
>> Cool. Cool.
um so far. So that so that's it for now.
We'll see you until next time
>> for me.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Logic. God bless you. But if
there's just one more thing I could ask,
this one's like a a lighter question,
but it's like about the law. I And
again, like I know uh again, I was
really feeling guilty about some of the
things I said about Paul, but it does
seem like like what's the basis for
abolishing the law? like for like saying
circumcision isn't necessary or like you
know like the allowing people to eat
food that's dedicated to idols when the
Old Testament says don't do that. Like
why does he allow these things?
>> Like I'm not trying to insult him. I'm
just I'm just like wanting to understand
why he allows things that were forbidden
before when Jesus says like I'm not I'm
not coming to like abolish the law.
>> Yeah. So John Walton talks about this is
that the the Torah was meant to be a
light for the nations that Israel
surrounded. What could they do to
project God's goodness and light to
those nations? And so certain rituals
were put in place, certain food
restrictions were put in place to
represent order, to represent uh these
things that they would have understood.
But when the gospel is meant to go out
to all the nations that that is that
that's going to change things because
like if you're witnessing to people in
like Britannia or in like you know
Africa like they're going to be like
well what these food laws don't apply
that doesn't represent goodness to us
why would these apply here so when it
goes out of that cultural millu where it
was situated in Canaan then it's like
okay well these certain things were for
a specific time for specific purposes
and now and Paul understands the
scriptures well so he's now that it's
expanding out to the whole world, what
matters is the spiritual aspects, uh the
the aspects of the new covenant to
represent God's goodness to the whole
world. And so that's what's sort of
going on with there.
>> Oh yeah, that that makes sense cuz like
Paul Paul's trying to spread it as far
as possible.
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah. Just uh kind of like what he just
mentioned, type in shadow. That's a key
thing to remember. Like if you look at
Hebrews 10, number of other places like
in Colossians, you'll see this concept
that's given of type and shadow and or
shadow and substance sometimes it's
said. So the shadow is sort of the thing
before the thing, but it's a sign of the
thing is going to be coming. And so when
the actual substance of the shadow is
there, you don't look through the shadow
anymore. That's the analogy actually
that Paul himself gives. Remember he
himself was a came out of a rabbitic
school. And then another one is the idea
of the law is a is a tutor to teach us
to Christ. Uh that's one way. And so the
idea is what part of what the law does
is show us our sinfulness. Shows us our
our lack of ability to do it on our own
to point us to Christ. Another term
sometimes given is a guardian. So until
something else happens, you have a
guardian until there's a proper age.
Well, when you have what needs to
happen, which again is Jesus, then you
have it fulfilled. But here's an
interesting thing to remember about
these discussions. Did Adam have the law
of Moses? Did Enoch have the law of
Moses? Do you see what I mean saying?
Did Abraham have the law of Moses? Did
Isaac have the law of Moses? Did Jacob
have the law of Moses? You go down the
list. Did Joseph have the law of Moses?
The answer is no to all those. And yet,
God is still dealing with men and women.
There are are things that he asks them
to do, tells them to do. And if you
notice, they're not always the same
things. And so what it means is each
time you have a covenant, a way that God
is dealing with man, there's essentially
terms that come with the covenant, what
we're supposed to do. So for a long
time, Israel was under the old covenant.
And that included people who were united
with Israel's God by being united to
Israel, the strangers who would join
among them. And they would have to do
those things like circumcision. But now
that you have the way people get linked
up, for lack of a better word, to the
one true God of the universe, it's not
by joining with a physical nation or
physical people. It's by joining with
Christ or rather being joined to him. So
it's a new covenant, which he says
before he dies. He says, "This is the
cup, new covenant, my blood poured out
for many." And so he's letting you know
we're entering into the new covenant. So
the the big thing to know there is what
is the difference between the old and
the new covenant? And um one book I
recommend on this is a book called
Progressive Covenantalism. I know it's a
big long title, but it shows the way
that the Old Testament laws are
fulfilled in Christ and what that means
for the believer going forward. Old
Testament, Old Testament, New Covenant.
You want to kind of start to learn the
uh the levels of continuity and
discontinuity between each. So it is
sort of a lifelong project of how to put
your Bible together, meaning how does
the Old and New Testament fit together?
But the right answer is it's through
Jesus. So picture an hourglass sand on
top, then it gets thin in the middle.
That's Jesus. Everything else after that
is filtered through him on the bottom of
the of the hourglass as well. But Jesus
is that center point. And that's what
the message is again. In fact, last
thing on this, Jesus's message himself
is about that, right? He says, "The law
and the prophet spoke of me." He says
this a number of time. The best example
is on the road to a mace with those
disciples when he says that. And then he
says things like that again and again
and again. So it's understanding we are
in a new covenant. So those things have
been abolished and that word is actually
in Hebrews get gets translated different
ways but the idea of abolished or
another word like it. It is in Hebrews
in relationship to specific things of
the law. And the big one there is the
priesthood. Jesus is our high priest,
right? But yet he's not of Levi. Well,
how does that work if we're strictly
under old covenant regulations? We're
not. So we are in a new covenant. But
here's the point of Hebrews. The new
covenant is superior. So whenever you
have people who want to try to push you
back into the old, it's been a
temptation since day one. That's what
the whole book of Galatians about.
Regalations is the antidote to people
trying to push the law on you when you
have Jesus.
>> All right, man. Like you guys, God bless
you. Thank you for this conversation. I
really appreciate it. God logic. God
bless you and your family. Keep me in
your prayers cuz I I want to become a
Christian. you know, keep being your
prayers. And uh who who said solar
system?
>> Sorry, I'm just doing a bunch of stuff
around the house.
>> Oh, that's you.
>> Yeah. Sorry. I'll mute myself, but
sorry, man.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, man. And you keep doing what
you're doing. You're bringing many
people out of Islam into, you know,
you're doing the right thing, you know.
God bless you guys. Thank you very much.
And uh hopefully maybe in a couple of
weeks I'll see you guys. But I
appreciate everything you've done for
me, brother. Thank you very much. Thank
you, Sie. Look, man, next next time we
talk, I'm I'm hoping to hear an official
testimony, man. We'll see.
>> I'm hoping, too. I will take my
Christian shahada in in in uh in Jesus's
name, right? I see you, bro.
>> God bless you, Sully. face.